[Musique]
François Ruffin bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement je suis donc
député représentant la nation c'est le
titre que je préfère c'est à dire que au
confondre je considère que ça fait
maintenant près de 25 ans que j'essaie
de représenter la nation ou les parts
les moins visibles de la nation d'abord
dans mon journal qui était fakir à la
radio avec Daniel Mermet à la Bassi j'y
suis dans mes films merci patron et
compagnie et maintenant parfois la
tribune de l'Assemblée nationale mais je
vois une continuité de mon parcours
je vois alors les gens le voient pas
mais il y a plein de papiers par terre
c'est quoi tous ces petits papiers c'est
mon fils de sécurité en général je
regarde pas mais quand je vais dans les
médias j'arrive toujours avec mes
paquets de documents parce que j'ai
bossé en amont et avant de passer ici à
finkerview on sait pas si on va nous
parler de l'Amérique latine des gazoduc
de l'Algérie de quoi donc on fait on
révise le coude et voilà
et ben écoutez bienvenue et donc on va
se parler aujourd'hui de où va la France
ça fait à peu près 5 ans qu'on s'est pas
vu
c'était fort agréable la première fois
et donc on va creuser aujourd'hui un peu
en détail le prisme de lecture de de
merci j'étais en train d'avaler ma
vosgienne c'est pour ça et François
Ruffin où va la France là si on devait
se revoir dans cinq ans pour refaire une
émission on en serait où selon votre
perception selon ta perception de
l'Industrie de l'Énergie du social de la
géopolitique de la guerre économique
dans cinq ans la France elle en est où
franchement je suis pas prophète et il
faut juste dire que la vérité c'est que
la question où va la France tu viens la
sortir moi je sais même pas que c'était
le thème de l'émission d'accord et je
sais que il y a pas pour moi de fatalité
dans l'histoire et c'est ce que les
hommes font et les femmes bien sûr je
veux dire que la crise de 1929 elle a
donné le New Deal aux États-Unis elle a
donné le nazisme en Allemagne elle a
donné le Front populaire en France donc
il y a des réponses qui peut être
nationales qui peut être différente
selon la structure des sociétés et selon
volonté des hommes et des femmes qui
l'habitent et donc évidemment moi je me
bagarre pour que on ait une issue de
l'histoire une suite qui soit plutôt
progressiste qui soit faite de
solidarité et qui fasse que les
personnes qui habitent notre pays et ben
elles puissent vivre au dignement se
loger dignement s'habiller dignement se
nourrir dignement et que il y ait pas du
gavage en haut et du rationnement en bas
moi je vais poser une question qui est
quel est le point commun
depuis les 2000 dernières années qu'il y
a entre toutes les crises que l'humanité
a pu traverser quel est le point commun
qu'il y a entre toutes les crises depuis
les 2000 dernières années
l'émission de Jacques Chancel radio
scoopy
j'étais pas né je crois bien
et à un moment il interroge sarde comme
ça et Dieu dans tout ça tu vois et ça
tombe comme ça un peu du ciel c'est le
cas de le dire mettons on a l'impression
que c'est pareil à un moment il y a
Daniel Mermet et d'autres qui avait fait
et qui avait repris les questions de
Jacques sens Chancel et ça faisait et ça
tombait sur une question au hasard et
l'inviter d'un seul coup il devait
répondre et Dieu dans tout ça mais toi
on a l'impression que c'est pareil
d'abord je sais pas du coup tu nous
offre un point tu offres un point
d'entrée on va prendre ce qui fait
d'abord dire de où je parle tu vois
on était dans la cuisine tout à l'heure
et il y a Bernadette qui est venu une
black qui est venue pour vider les
poubelles j'avais pas vu depuis
longtemps en plus et qui raconte un
petit peu sa vie je suis venu du Congo
Brazzaville quand j'étais à la
préfecture je savais pas lire pas écrire
mais je pleurais pour avoir mes papiers
et la France elle m'a porté ça
m'a apporté que à la mairie et ben j'ai
pris des cours de français maintenant
chez lire chez écrire et je me sens
mieux en gros c'est ce qu'on sentait moi
je suis quoi moi je suis là pour
défendre les Bernadette ici et défendre
Géraldine je vais te pendre dans mon
coin à Amiens qui travaille chez honnête
donc une société de ménage à l'hôpital
d'Amiens et qui prend le car le matin
comme Bernadette elle doit venir de
troisième couronne de la banlieue
parisienne et faire une heure une heure
et demie de transport pour venir ici tu
vois et ben là elle Géraldine elle pense
elle prend le car le matin elle vient
faire ses trois heures à l'hôpital pour
nettoyer les couloirs et elle repart et
elle a un chantier le soir voilà pour
qui je viens parler
donc
là j'étais un peu j'étais je t'ai envoyé
une question un peu un peu balaise d'un
coup bah oui 2000 ans et les crises en
général mais quel est le point commun
dans toutes ces crises et ben le point
commun c'est que la réponse à mieux ah
mais je te lance après sur le prochain
sujet c'est notre introduction qui
complètement raté d'ailleurs on en est
sorti à chaque fois par une augmentation
de consommation énergétique
c'est à dire ta crise de 29 la crise de
14 la guerre de 39 à chaque fois on en
est ressorti pour une consommation
énergétique accrue
la crise qu'on est en train de vivre en
ce moment c'est qu'on ne pourra pas
repartir sur une augmentation de
consommation énergétique accrue donc moi
la question que je te pose c'est comment
toi qui est député qui a les mains dans
le cambouis qui enracinait localement
qui va voir les problèmes des gens des
vrais pas tu vois ce que je veux dire
comment toi tu vas faire pour réussir à
ce que les gens puissent avoir un toit
sur la tête avoir un service public qui
tient encore la route alors que notre
décrue énergétique va être affolante
tu sais enfin en ce moment je suis pas
mal
interrogé par ce qui s'est passé pendant
les guerres la nécessité pour moi en
gros c'est Roosevelt 1942 vous êtes 1942
il entre en guerre et il lui manque de
Bombardier il lui manque une langue de
temps qui lui manque de porte-avion ça
l'armée représente 2% du budget
américain et à l'arrivée deux ans plus
tard ça représente choix 47% du budget
américain et il a démultiplié c'est
capacités de production de la même
manière que il produit une économie de
guerre je pense qu'on doit produire une
économie de guerre climatique et ce que
fait Roosevelt aussi et ce qui me paraît
essentiel c'est que partant d'une crise
majeure la Deuxième Guerre mondiale il
établit un certain niveau d'égalité à
l'intérieur du pays le taux d'impôt sur
les sociétés va être multiplié par 16 tu
vois le taux d'impôt sur les revenus il
me semble que c'est par 40 bon on
atteint 90% dans les traces supérieur tu
sais d'imposition sur le revenu et ça
produit un certain niveau d'égalité qui
fait qu'il y a une acceptation de la
société d'aller dans le sens commun
l'Angleterre au même moment elle met en
place des mesures de rationnement
finalement et là ce qui est incroyable
c'est que c'est pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale que l'espérance de vie
des classes populaires a le plus
progressé en Angleterre pendant tout le
20e siècle elle a gagné cette année
pourquoi parce que en même temps qu'on
s'est dit qu'il fallait que le bas le
haut pardon on baisse le plafond on a
relevé le plancher du bas et on leur a
dit vous aurez de quoi manger vous aurez
de quoi vous soigner tu vois et je pense
que la réponse à la crise aujourd'hui
qu'on traverse qui pour moi pas
seulement une crise de l'énergie il
faudrait j'espère en venir à une crise
de la démocratie et qui est une crise de
la démocratie organisée voulue bon mais
la réponse
séditieux ça oui mais il m'arrive
d'avoir des points de vue c'est déçu un
petit peu quoi mais des enquêtes aussi
pour ces édition non
[Musique]
moi j'étais quand même l'une des rares
pour personnalités qui s'est fait
surveiller par les deux Bernards en même
temps par Bernard Arnault et par Bernard
scorsini je sais pas si tu voudras en
faire un point de mais voilà c'est moi
qui était sous surveillance bon mais
donc
voilà
l'exigence d'égalité je pense qu'on ne
pourra
accepter des mesures de réduction de
notre consommation d'énergie que si
jamais il y a le plafond qui redescendu
et le plancher qui est relevé et tu
m'autorises à te couper c'est ce que tu
fais de toute façon en général sans me
demander mon autorisation
je m'excuse d'avance hier il y avait la
conférence de l'opek pardon
il y a une question d'une journaliste
concernant la pénurie la précarité
énergétique
et la réponse a été mais vous savez ma
très cher dam en Afrique il y a plus de
600 millions de personnes qui ont pas
l'eau l'électricité ça c'est la vraie
précarité énergétique la journaliste
faisait référence elle a précarité
énergétique que l'Europe est en train de
subir
sur ce nivellement
cette égalité d'accès à l'énergie
comment on peut mondialiser ce concept
est-ce que les 680 millions d'Africains
qui ont pas accès à l'eau l'électricité
on doit le relever le plafond de la
consommation énergétique et est-ce que
les consommations énergétiques
européennes et occidentales doivent être
plafonnés et niveler en fonction de la
précarité énergétique africaine il
s'agit d'aller vers ça maintenant et
c'est évident qu'on va pas le faire en
claquant des doigts mais il va y avoir
une autorisation à tous ceux qui sont en
bas de relever plancher et une
obligation pour ceux qui sont en haut
d'abaisser le plafond mais ça ça va pas
se faire par la main visible du marché
si on laisse faire la main visiblement
du marché elle va produire le pire dans
dans les temps qu'on traverse c'est à
dire que c'est le porte on est monnaie
qui va devenir le régulateur qu'il est
déjà et au fond le porte-monnaie font
que ceux qui sont en haut ne ressemblent
aucune limite à leur hyper consommation
et vont continuer d'hyper consommer et
vraisemblablement consommer encore
montage tandis que ceux qui sont en bas
sont immédiatement restreints dès que on
dit qu'il y a une augmentation de 5% où
là il va y avoir 15% pour eux ça va
représenter quelque chose de gigantesque
et d'un faisable alors que ça sera
indolore pour ceux qui sont donc ça ne
peut pas se faire seulement par les prix
du marché ça doit se faire par une
volonté de dire bah voilà il y a un
rationnement il y a un quota il y a un
plafond qu'on ne doit pas dépasser tu
vois c'est la nécessité de restaurer des
limites le mot limite est un mot
important je me souviens j'étais allé au
Monaco yacho à tu nous racontais tout à
l'heure comment tu avais fréquenté des
univers de riches mais moi aussi comment
on avait acquis
il m'est arrivé aussi comme reporter de
et avec plaisir tu vois d'aller à Megève
assister à des tournois de polo sur
glace d'aller faire le le faux gendre de
millionnaire de chips français qui va
s'exiler fiscalement en Belgique et
rencontre des cabinets conseils va
acheter de l'immobilier fréquente un
cercle
hérité de Léopold Senghor ou des choses
comme ça bon avec avec grand bonheur et
là je me trouvais au Monaco il yacho et
il y a un moment où il remettent le
greenlyber le label vert tu vois donc
c'était le yacht écologique je demande à
le voir je m'attendais à voilier en bois
et là je tombe sur un yacht trois ponts
en acier noir et tu as complètement
écrasé par la masse je vois ça et je
demande au président du jury mais
qu'est-ce qui est écologique là-dedans
il me dit bah voilà c'est pas une blague
je te jure que c'est pas une blague
pourquoi ta victime non il m'a dit quand
on va aux toilettes
ça reste à l'intérieur c'est pas jeté
dans la mer et les plans ont été faits
sur ordinateur et pas sur papier tu vois
et je demande mais combien ça consomme à
leur truc comme ça ils me disent moi
entre 800 et 1200 litres de l'heure tu
vois et c'est l'une du des taxé tu sais
bon donc et il y avait un yacht il
s'appelait le limite laisse le sang
limite ça dit tout là on vit des temps
pour moi le mot qui doit dominer notre
époque là c'est le mot indécence on est
dans un temps
d'incroyable moi j'ai fait ma campagne
électorale en faisant compter les gens
avec moi est-ce que pour moi jusque 3 1
2 3 10.000 euros pour Jeff Bezos le
patron d'Amazon qui paye pas ses impôts
en France alors que le boulanger du coin
est taxé à 24% et ça veut dire qu'on
pendant ces trois secondes il a gagné
autant que Hayat qui était ma suppléante
accompagnante d'enfants situations
handicap pendant un an enfin c'est du
délire là que tu vois on te parle de
crise je sais que ça fait marxiste de
base tu vois mais enfin c'est tellement
gros comme une vache au milieu du
couloir et tous les jours il faudrait
qu'on voit pas cette vache au milieu du
couloir quant à les échos le journal de
mon ami Bernard Arnault qui est quand
même pas pour le coup un repère de
marxiste qui a qui annonce que dividende
record donc de tous les temps pour les
entreprises du CAC 40 44 milliards
d'euros quand il t’annonce que l'an
dernier les salaires des PDG français
ont doublé
pendant la crise covid les milliardaires
français ils ont fait plus 300 milliards
d'euros ça veut rien dire on sait pas ce
que ça veut dire + 300 milliards d'euros
alors j'ai j'ai toujours de donner des
images parce que les gens et en
particulier tu vois les gens qui sont
pas qui sont déjà du mal à aller
jusqu'au 2000 euros ils vont pas aller à
à 300 milliards le PIB de ma région
Hauts-de-France que je reconnais
toujours pas moi c'est picardians moi
c'est la Picardie toujours tu vois mais
c'est 150 milliards d'euros le PIB de la
région Grand Est c'est 150 milliards
d'euros donc il faut imaginer que
pendant un an les ouvriers les employés
les architectes les médecins les
gendarmes les Hospitaliers de ces deux
immenses régions entre Strasbourg et
caler entre Dunkerque et Beauvais entre
Reims et l'île tout ça a travaillé
pendant un an pour enrichir les
milliardaires français c'est tellement
on est tellement dans un temps alors je
continue dans mes chiffres tu m'arrêtes
quand tu veux mais
en 20 ans le PIB des
500 fortune française il était et qui va
les fortunes le patrimoine des 500
fortune française était de 5 % du PIB il
y a 20 ans on est aujourd'hui à 38% du
PIB donc c'est tu vois d'ailleurs ça y
est c'est parti mais le symbole pour moi
de l'époque c'est hors pa ce qui s'est
passé chez leur père donc dans les
maisons de retraite on découvre que les
personnes âgées sont rationnées sur leur
croûtons de soupe qu'elles sont
rationnées sur leurs couches culottes
quels sont réactionnées sur leur gâteau
de Pépito que en vérité m'a expliqué le
journaliste Victor Castanet
elles étaient elles avaient faim la fin
c'était installé dans les EHPAD parce
que il est nourrissait pas et pour du
coup quand même trouver des coupes fin
en fait ils donnaient ils ont dit on va
donner des faire prescrire des
médicaments de la sécurité sociale comme
ça c'est la sécu qui payait la bouffe tu
vois le rationnement donc tout est
rationnel et à l'inverse le seul truc
qui était pas rationné c'était les
profits de hors période et les salaires
de ces dirigeants et je pense que
l'affaire en courant en ce moment bref
non enfin on verra bien ce que ça donne
mais
là on est pour moi dans cette histoire
là elle est la caricature le symbole de
notre monde avec donc là je te dis les
milliardaires les fortunes tu arrives
même pas à savoir combien il y a de zéro
il y a derrière en revanche dès qu'il
s'agit des gens là c'est à l'euro près
pour reprendre du Bruno Le Maire tu vois
il va donner 8 milliards d'euros aux
grandes entreprises de ce pays là c'est
dans le budget c'est la baisse de la
CVAE sur la contribution sur la valeur
ajoutée des entreprises c'est des trucs
chiant tu vois c'est 8 milliards d'euros
les deux tiers vont aller au plus
grosses entreprises du pays ça a passé
comme une lettre à la poste bon il y en
a 50 milliards d'euros au total tous les
ans de dons au plus riches c'est-à-dire
que on a déjà une mondialisation qui
produit une inégalisation interne ça
c'est un théorème de externe bon c'est
des économistes à l'ouverture de
l'économie répond des inégalisations
internes donc en fait qu'est-ce qui se
passe tu as les les ouvriers à qui on
demande de regarder vers l'est et vers
le bas parce qu'on va dire au mec de
chez Dunlop ouais mais attends tu peux
pas être payé plus de 12 euros de
l'heure parce que regarde en Estonie il
produisent des pneus pour pour bien
moins cher que toi donc on leur demande
de regarder vers l'est et vers le bas et
tu as le patron de Total lui qui
s'augmente de 52% l'année dernière ce
qui dit mais regardez le patron de exon
il est bien mieux payé que moi donc lui
le haut regarde vers plus haut et vers
l'ouest tu vois le truc ça c'est donc et
non que devrait faire l'état dans ce
cadre là il devrait essayer de peut-être
pas d'arriver à égalité mais d'essayer
de rétablir un petit peu les plateaux de
la balance et ben tu as un état tu fais
l'inverse et qui décide pendant ce temps
là que sur les accompagnants de
d'enfants en situation de handicap ça
sera l'euro près elles seront pas
augmentées bien qu’étant employés de
l'éducation nationale elles vont rester
largement sous le SMIC et sous le seuil
de pauvreté et qu'en revanche on va
donner 8 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires aux entreprises donc on
vit un temps d'indécence incroyable
revenons à tes bateaux il y a un yacht
qui a été designé pour la crise
énergétique c'est le Faucon Maltais
tiens à voir c'est un yacht avec trois
mains mais bon mais de la même manière
des portes-conteneurs qui avec des cerfs
qui peuvent être faits avec des voiles
c'est là c'est pas comme si on avait pas
des techniques à notre disposition
puisque pendant des siècles on a quand
même transformé des transportés pardon
des marchandises sur les mers
par des moyens qui étaient extrêmement
écologiques alors tu me lances sur sur
le débat sur la crise énergétique c'est
toi qui a pas besoin de faire beaucoup
d'efforts pourquoi tu te lances tout
seul dans un débat sur la crise alors la
voile la voile il y a des entreprises
qui font venir du cacao du café à la
voile ça m'est beaucoup plus de temps
c'est beaucoup plus cher
est-ce que la voile peut soutenir une
économie mondialisée
est-ce que l'écologie
peut soutenir une économie mondialisée
basée sur une fonction exponentielle
basée sur la mégalomanie de la
consommation est-ce qui quel changement
de paradigme tu vois ce profiler pour
temporiser ce monstre qui depuis les 50
dernières années
détruit le biotope les gens les âmes
créer des conflits je pense qu'il y a
une chose dont tu dis pas qu'elle le
détruit mais c'est la démocratie et bon
je vais dire moi je suis protectionniste
depuis longtemps c'est à dire que je
souhaite une relocalisation des
économies il s'agit pas de faire de
produire du café du chocolat on va pas y
arriver ici en Picardie tu vois mais
bientôt mais peut-être mais
c'est Kens qui disait écoute que la
culture que les idées que les livres
soient internationales il le faut
mais en revanche que tout ce qui peut
être de l'ordre de la production locale
soit de la production locale voilà
c'était et donc évidemment il y a un
distinguo à opérer entre des valeurs de
tu vois le siècle des Lumières était un
siècle qui transportait les idées d'un
pays à l'autre et d'une production qui
quand elle peut être nationale doit
rester naturel mais donc je te dis la
démocratie parce que
pour moi
Samuel linkington donc tu vois qui écrit
ensuite le choc des utilisations mais en
1975 il rend un rapport
à la Commission Trilatérale que tu
connais donc qui réunit les élites
américaines
européennes et japonaise et c'est un
rapport sur
crise de démocratie mais pour lui c'est
comme une crise de foi c'est qu'il y en
a trop et il explique dans ce rapport
qui est public qu'on connaît qu'il était
à l'époque mais il dit voilà on a un
problème la démocratie c'est bien mais
il faut toujours qu'il y en ait quand
même qui soit pas dedans ça va mieux
quand il y a pas les Noirs à l'intérieur
ça va être mieux quand il y a pas les
pauvres à l'intérieur ça va mieux quand
il y a pas les femmes à l'intérieur ça
dépend des moments mais voilà et
aujourd'hui il dit comment vous voulez
que les dirigeants dirigent
tranquillement parce que en ce moment on
est donc dans l'après 68 les années 70
1975 en ce moment il est chez Jean
prennent la démocratie au sérieux il
manifeste il protestent ils s'organise
il vote bon c'est pas possible comment
vous que dans ces conditions nos
gouvernants gouvernent tranquillement et
il dit
ces textos là ce que j'ai dit là c'est
un peu la paraphrase mais ce qui dit
ensuite texto il nous faut restaurer de
l'apathie politique
c'est écrit dans le rapport de Samuel
entington et on comprend pas
ce qui se passe depuis 40 ans le temps
dans lequel on se trouve si jamais on
voit pas qu'il y a une stratégie mise en
place par les dominants pour échapper à
cette démocratie qui était trop vivace
alors ça tu vois Huntington il parle des
États-Unis on a des témoignages sur les
boîtes américaines dans lesquelles le
lundi matin les ouvriers vont plus à
l'usine où on est dans une espèce de
démission permanente et où le capital se
dit mais bon sang est-ce qu'on va encore
pouvoir continuer à faire tourner la
boutique
mais ce qui s'est passé avec le covid
tu vois et là dans mon coin la même
histoire un peu donc mon coin les
cathédrales de Picardie Damien de
Beauvais ont été construites sur le
textile depuis des siècles bon
1975 c'est mon année de naissance
l'année du rapportington et c'est aussi
le sommet de la protection textile en
Picardie jamais on a produit autant mais
c'est un temps où quand on regarde dans
le Val de Nièvre dans le lieu de de
l'Empire saint frère et bien il y avait
des grèves tous les jours enfin
régulièrement il y avait des hausse de
salaire il y avait des revendications il
y avait à l'époque une CFDT qui était
plus à gauche que la CGT et donc c'était
un temps comme ça en passé par dessus
les murs on libérait les camarades enfin
tu vois c'était des temps de
manifestation et bien comment ils ont
répondu à ce rapport de force
ils ont rapporté ce rapport de force en
finalement comme ils perdait sur ce
terrain là en décidant de changer de
terrain et à ce moment là qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont signé un truc
qui s'appelle je sais pas si ça tu
connais les Écores AMF les accords
multiples les accords multi-fi fibres
c'est les premiers accords de
mondialisation sur le textile et ça va
voir comme effet très rapide que une
délocalisation d'abord dans les pays du
Maghreb puis à Madagascar puis en Inde
puis en Chine dix ans plus tard en 1985
il y a presque plus rien du textile en
Picardie
tout est quasiment démoli et en revanche
je regarde les coupures de presse de
l'époque tu as des ouvertures du resto
du coeur tu as des dépressions tu as des
plans de licenciement en série et tu as
du malaise qui installer et là c'est
clair que qu'est-ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment-là 10 ans plus tard 1985 et 1985
c'est le moment c'est pour ça que je
pense cette date c'est le moment où
Bernard Arnault rachète l'Empire Boussac
saint frère qui va être le point
d'origine de sa fortune tu vois parce
que il vient il promet au milieu
d'ouvrier qui va garder les emplois et
en fait il va tout liquider il va le
garder que la pépite qui se trouve à
l'intérieur qui est Dior sur lequel il
va fonder son empire du luxe donc basé
sur un mensonge et donc voilà et tout le
reste va être démantelé
parce que il y a eu c'est pas le fruit
de hasard c'est pas par la main
invisible du marché c'est pas par la
Providence c'est par un choix qui est
finalement moins un choix de recherche
du profit pour moi évidemment ils
allaient y avoir des salaires moins
chers
au Maghreb que en Picardie mais surtout
pour moi c'est un choix de pouvoir de
garder le pouvoir
d'inverser le rapport de force et donc
là là et ben donc avec des c'est pour ça
que je suis dit au fond le processus de
mondialisation
un impact sur la fiscalité je veux bien
développer tout ça je suis très à l'aise
je me permets ou pas sur la fiscalité
regarde ce qui se passe depuis il faut
prendre tu sais c'est en 1982 Lionel
Jospin qui dit nous ouvrons une
parenthèse libérale et qu'il était
Premier secrétaire du Parti socialiste
tu vois bon en fait la parenthèse
libérale on est encore coincé à
l'intérieur donc ce qui se passe sur le
terrain de la fiscalité c'est une baisse
baisse constante de ce qu'on appelle des
taxations des bases mobiles qu'est-ce
qui est mobile le capital est très
mobile il peut partir d'un endroit à un
autre qu'est-ce qui est très mobile
aussi les firmes elles peuvent menacer
de partir d'un endroit à un autre
qu'est-ce qui est beaucoup moins oublié
les PME les artisans du coin qui va pas
partir au Bermudes le petit propriétaire
de son appartement juste le nom moi je
vais pas aller me délocaliser au
Luxembourg ou en Andorre tu vois ou
encore moins à Jersey enfin bon et donc
du coup on a un glissement la fiscalité
des bases mobiles vers les bases
immobiles et donc tu regardes l'impôt
sur les sociétés il était à 50% au
milieu des années 80 1985 il est
précisément à 50% là le taux affiché est
de 25% mais en vérité on sait que les
sociétés du CAC 40 elles sont à 4% total
paye 0% d'impôt sur les sociétés pour
mémoire comme ça et il est à 24% pour
les PME tu vois et en revanche quelle
est la type de fiscalité qui va
augmenter c'est la TVA c'est la CSG
c'est ce type de contribution là ça va
être la taxe foncière par exemple et
donc et tout donc c'est un je l'ai dit
dumping fiscal parce que il y a la
menace de partir et en fait c'est les
multinationales peuvent être comme dans
un espèce de supermarché où elles vont
chercher les plus faibles normes
environnemental le plus bas coût fiscal
tout à coup énergétique aussi j'en viens
à ma question
comment on fait pour relocaliser une
industrie quand on a un prix de
l'électricité qui a été multiplié par X
un prix du gaz qui a été multiplié par X
quand on entend une petite commune dire
le prix de l'électricité s'est multiplié
par 16 le prix du gaz multiplié par 32
comment on fait pour relocaliser dans
une Europe qui n'a pas d'énergie de bon
marché et qui en plus maintenant à des
problèmes d'approvisionnement dire quand
même que la crise Julia de la crise de
l'électricité c'est pas les mêmes il y a
c'est toi le grand spécialiste statue
alors tu pourrais te mettre dans le
fauteuil et me donner des leçons je suis
pas censé donner des leçons je suis pas
censé donner mon point de vue quand même
la neutralité des journalistes je n'y
crois pas ça tombe bien je suis pas
journaliste non journalistes non plus
rien neutre dans cette église nul ne
traverse l'existence de manière neutre
la crise du gaz est une crise
d'importation mais je veux dire la crise
de l'électricité c'est une crise qu'on
se produit nous-même quand même
aujourd'hui la hausse des cours de
l'électricité c'est un truc qui est n'a
rien à voir avec la réalité du marché
qui ne voit plus être à marcher par
ailleurs je veux dire c'est le choix tu
vois enfin il faudrait revenir
responsabilité de Sarkozy Macron et
compagnie de la Commission européenne
ils ont tu vois quand on a qu'un marteau
on voit tous les problèmes sous forme de
clous
ce sont des ayatollas de la concurrence
ils ne voient toutes l'existence que
sous un prisme qui est la concurrence la
concurrence la concurrence le rail tu
vois on a une loi sur le nouveau pacte
ferroviaire à l'intérieur il y avait 87
fois le mot concurrence il y avait 0
fois le mot réchauffement zéro fois le
mot climat zéro fois le mot biodiversité
0 fois le mot passager tu vois c'était
pas sale qui comptait ce qui comptait
c'était du juste d'instaurer de la
concurrence de la concurrence de la
concurrence regarde ce qu'ils font sur
les universités c'est à nouveau le leur
prisme c'est la concurrence la
concurrence la concurrence tout n'est vu
qu'avec cette concurrence et évidemment
le il a fallu que alors qu'on avait
quand même EDF-GDF c'était quand même un
truc qui marchait et qui a marché
pendant longtemps l'héritage de Marcel
Paul bon et finalement qui a marché
pendant longtemps y compris avec les
industriels comme bénéficiaires d'un
d'une situation stable sur le terrain
énergétique mais non plan à long terme
et ben la possibilité à long terme il a
fallu qu'il casse ça qu'ils en face des
petits bouts des espaces du mécano ah tu
vois j'ai une citation qui me revient
d'un d'un paysan arboriculteur il
s'appelle
Régis mince je suis sûr que je vais
retrouver son nom au fur et à mesure tu
vois j'ai Régis au bonheur tu vois qui
habitait
pas un Ardèche qui est à côté qui est
dans la Drôme donc qui avait des
abricotiers et
alors les crises de l'abricotier crise
des arbres fruitiers pourquoi alors tu
as même il était la FNSEA il est
toujours et tu vois des conflits
internes à la FNSEA ça nous fait glisser
mais c'est pas grave elle est conflits
internes à la FNA parce que lui il est
quelque chose qui réclame de la main
d'oeuvre tandis que le ceux qui dirige
FNSEA c'est là où il y a peu de main
d'oeuvre tu vois par exemple dans mon
coin ça va être les grandes surfaces de
blé mais lui et qui ont très peu de main
d'oeuvre alors que lui il en reste dans
de l'arboriculture
dans quelque chose qui a beaucoup de
manœuvre donc il peut pas être
concurrent compétitif face à un fruit
apporter d'Espagne avec un plus bas coût
de manœuvre d'autant plus que si c'est
des énergique voilà et puis avec des
travailleurs détachés à l'intérieur donc
sont son truc se casse la figure mais
bon et donc un moment il dit je suis
allé à Bruxelles et j'ai rencontré là
les
pas les commissaires mais les
techniciens du lait et il me dit ne me
parlait que de concurrence concurrence
concurrence ouverture du marché
ouverture du marché ouverture du marché
et il a cette phrase il me dit j'ai
rencontré les petits soldats de Milton
Friedman donc Milton Friedman étant
étant cette économiste de l'école de
Chicago qui pense le marché le marché le
marché avec Hayek bon et au fond ça va
faire une longue digression mais tu vois
sur ce lait qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait
ils ont décidé de déréguler le marché du
lait donc de supprimer les quotas parce
que c'est un marché où chacun avait son
son
le droit de production pour pas qu'il y
ait pas trop de lait sur sur le marché
et que ça produite des une baisse des
cours il y avait un minimum garanti dans
le prix du lait ils ont cassé tous ces
instruments là qu'est-ce que ça a fait
bah ça fait le prix du lait à plonger ça
a tué des milliers et des milliers
d'agriculteurs mais alors là où c'est
plus terrible que vraiment tu te dis ce
sont des fanatiques faut voir que
l'idéologie elle est vraiment de leur
côté moi je suis franchement je peux
vous dire que je suis un pragmatique je
suis un bricolage j'essaye de voir ce
qui peut marcher ce qui peut pas marcher
dans le truc mais eux ils se sont cassés
la gueule sur le lait qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont fait ils ont recommencé avec la
betterave mais la même chose il y avait
des quotas de production il y avait une
régulation du marché on avait sorti la
betterave de du des cours mondiaux pour
avoir tu vois un truc qui se tient année
après année bah non ils ont bazardé
toute ça et ça a eu la même conséquence
mais ils ont fait pareil sur sur de gaz
et surtout sur l'électricité parce que
l'électricité on a des moyens de
production on n'est pas dans la dans la
dépendance de la même manière qu'on
était dirigés par des banques si je
t'écoute bien non c'est pas des banques
tu vois c'est pas des banques ce sont
c'est l'idéologie qui dit pas ce sont
des idéologues et on a une idéologie
alors il y a deux choses il y a une
idéologie qui est profondément ancrée
dans leur cerveau et que il ne il la
répète comme des perroquets sans même se
rendre compte qu'ils soient habités par
une idéologie evidemment c'est les
idéologies qui sont les plus terribles
que celles qui sont intériorisées à ce
point-là qui ne se présente pas comme
étant des idéologies et il y a une
deuxième chose dont il faudra parler
peut-être un moment et donc pour moi
l'affaire colère là est
une illustration c'est que on parle de
lobby
mais le mot lobby est trop faible le mot
je te coupe pour moi pour moi je vais te
dire pour moi exceptionnellement pour
moi ce n'est que l'écume des choses
tu comprends ce que ça veut dire pour
moi ça n'est que les Cumes des choses
parce que je vois la population
française exposée à des risques
dramatiques je vais les exposer puis on
va essayer de développer les questions
ensemble je parlais de la crise
énergétique la relocalisation quand on
voit qu'un boulanger se fait
tondre par sa facture d'électricité
quand on voit quelqu'un qui travaille le
vert pour faire des bouteilles ben c'est
terminé quand on voit des boîtes en
Belgique dire bah là ça coûte trop cher
en énergie je vais plus produire quand
on voit des agriculteurs qui peuvent
plus fournir à des prix décents pour des
fertilisants alors que les sols en
France sont un peu ravagés donc il faut
il faut les doper donc quand on voit des
risques alimentaires des risques
énergétiques
l'affaire colère pour moi c'est l'écume
des choses
si tu veux on y reviendra après mais
juste dire pourquoi ça n'est pas l'écume
des choses parce que aujourd'hui on a je
te disais les lobbys c'est un mot trop
faible parce que le lobby suppose une
pression de l'extérieur or aujourd'hui
on a un état qui est colonisé de
l'intérieur et si tu veux c'est dur
comme propos c'est l'évidence
regarde ils sont pas condamnés ces gens
là ils sont mis en examen
présomption d'innocence
la prise illégale d'intérêt tu vois
dans cette petite affaire c'est pour moi
c'est comme Al Capone qui tombe pour
fraude fiscale ils sont encore jugés ces
gens-là et je vais te dire au fond
l'essentiel de ce qu'ils ont fait ça a
été de faire de la prise légale
d'intérêt donc il y a ils vont je sais
pas s'ils seront jugés ou pas jugés mais
c'est le tribunal de l'histoire et
populaire quelque part qui devra établir
leur bilan et montrer quelle est la
réalité de leur bilan je te prends des
choses comme ça mais la raison
d'innocence
la totale innocence parce que
faudrait voir mais parce que à la limite
leur ce qu'ils font c'est de rendre
légal la prise du pays par les intérêts
privés donc c'est même pas du domaine de
la justice là ils vont être attrapés par
un fil peut-être mais l'essentiel de ce
qu'ils ont fait Alcatel
livré à Nokia avec la casse d'un outil
essentiel industriel Alstom livré à
General Electric technique pour les
Américains mais ça c'est les choses mais
tu regardes le bilan fiscal c'est quoi
c'est de décider qu'on vide les caisses
de l'État est-ce que ça te fait penser
l'excellence soviétique quand elle s'est
effondrée et que des oligarques ce sont
servis un peu à gauche à droite je sais
pas parce que ça voudrait dire que ça va
pas tenir et je sais pas si c'est pas
capable de tenir j'en sais rien est-ce
que c'est là où je peux te dire que pour
moi c'est pas marginal
évidemment le M toutes ces couleurs je
te dis à quel point c'est ça n'est qu'à
présent l'innocence quel point ça n'est
qu'un petit fil de rien du tout méprise
le fait que on est un état qui soit
colonisé par les intérêts privés jusqu'à
son sommet mais tu lis des bouquins
comme la caste tu vois tu as un
catalogue c'est un espèce de botin
mondain de tout les
inspecteurs des finances qui pantoufle
et qui rétropendouffe avec en vérité BNP
Paribas qui dirige Bercy tu as
l'impression en tout cas d'une confusion
entre les deux donc systémique non mais
donc ça a des du coup comment on va
pouvoir affronter
toutes les crises que tu viens de
mentionner et auxquelles je veux qu'on
apporte des réponses on va y venir mais
si jamais
le l'outil qu'on a l'un des outils et
quand même l'état la démocratie qui ne
doit permettre aux habitants de faire
des choix et que au fond il y a une
démocratie confisquée un état confisqué
voilà la question que ça pose mais pour
tout ce que tu viens de lister au fond
je crois que on a le choix entre deux
orientations c'est le marché ou la
volonté c'est à dire soit on laisse
faire le marché et le marché va décider
que le boulanger du coin il pourra il
pourra plus payer ses factures donc il
devra fermer soit il y a la volonté qui
prend le dessus la volonté politique la
volonté collective de se dire
quels sont nos besoins
non pas être dans une économie qui
s'auto régulent tu vois c'est quand
Guilhem un philosophe qui disait que il
y a des règles dans la société mais il y
a aucune règle qui n'est d'elle-même il
n'y a pas d'auto régulation la règle
elle arrive toujours d'un extérieur et
donc là croire qu'on va aller vers une
auto régulation du marché c'est de la
fiction c'est de la foutaise c'est juste
pour avoir la paresse du laisser faire
et à laisser faire un laisser aller qui
enrichit les riches qui va appauvrir
encore plus tu vois en bas donc la
question c'est comment on fait pour
avoir de la volonté de se dire
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on veut
produire mais aussi éventuellement
qu'est-ce qu'on ne veut plus produire et
que ça soit des choix qui soit opérés
ensemble et que ça soit pas laissé à la
main invisible du marché ou aux
actionnaires je te réponds qu'est-ce que
tu peux te permettre de consommer
oui mais c'est la question dans
Qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on veut
produire et qu'est-ce qu'on ne veut plus
produire tu vois c'est la question mais
tu vois
tu sais que par exemple sur les sur les
questions industrielles c'était le cœur
de mon combat de dire je vais te donner
un exemple
Gilles Legendre qui vient de nous dire
que
il a arrêté son sèche-linge et tu vois
pédagogique donc qu'est-ce qu'il avait
avoir je sais pas un temps car ville tu
vois ce que c'est un truc pour porter le
linge
et tu vois donc c'est le début de mon
film merci patron je sais pas si tu te
souviens où je descends des trucs et je
décroche mon t-shirt mais quand j'en
discutais avec les ouvriers de chez
WHIRLPOOL qui produisait des sèche-linge
donc les quand il y a un piqué des rêves
tu sais on a des temps pour discuter
comme ça et j'en disais mais tu sais moi
au fond sèche-linge moi j'en ai pas
besoin j'en veux pas le vent il fait le
boulot depuis 2000 ans il y a pas raison
que le vent il arrête de faire ça quoi
il me dit mais c'est pareil on n'a pas
besoin de sèche-linge des bruits très
bien sans donc il faut se dire que on
peut se passer du sèche-linge et
peut-être qu'on doit le faire tu vois et
c'est on en discutant avec des ouvriers
qui produit en revanche est-ce que je
vais me passer une machine à laver par
exemple non moi j'ai pas envie je te dis
j'ai pas envie de me remettre à
laver avec du savon toutes mes fringues
peut-être en Inde qui s'appelle les
dobbies pour ça bah oui mais j'ai pas
envie justement j'ai pas envie non plus
qu'on ait une caste spéciale pour ça
évolue à cette tâche et à d'autres
tâches moi je suis pour une juste
répartition des tâches qui a amené dans
la société et qu'il y ait pas des des
oisifs qui soient hors de ces tâches là
mais bon mais donc peut-être qu'on peut
aller vers des sèche-linge des
lave-linge pardon des lave-linge
collectifs que ils vont avoir une
moindre
[Musique]
production de lave-linge maintenant en
France c'était ma bagarre sur Whirlpool
moi je me suis venu vous voir le
ministère de l'économie en disant mais
vous vous rendez compte la Suisse la
Petite Suisse elle a grande Suisse bon
si tu veux tu es Suisse non mais j'adore
les Suisses
la grande Suisse la grande Suisse qui
nous a envoyé Rousseau alors à la grande
Suisse je parle de Jean-Jacques
et donc et donc
elle a deux usines de production de
lave-linge t'imagines nous la France je
vais pas dire la grande France mais
quand même la grande France
on a zéro il nous reste 0
usine de production de lave-linge donc
oui je pense que par exemple on pourrait
avoir dans notre pays l'usine de je
reviens à ma question du coup ça
signifie aujourd'hui de
avoir la possibilité que ça soit pas
l'économie qui décide de ce qui est
produit mais que ça soit les gens le
peuple le le représentants qui se disent
ben voilà ce qui nous paraît utile au
fond il faut aller comme pas pu la voir
en temps de guerre je disais je parlais
de ça tout à l'heure
deux économies différentes une économie
des besoins
et là c'est
assuré de quoi se produire se nourrir se
vêtir de survie non c'est pas une
économie de survie qui était déjà le
casque
là on va rentrer pour une économie
de survie c'est une économie de la
dignité c'est une économie de la
garantie que les besoins les besoins
essentiels sont
remplies pour toute la population tu
vois et à côté de ça c'est quoi les
besoins essentiels c'est se chauffer se
nourrir ce vêtir
et se nourrir tu l'as dit et se soigner
tu vois ce sont et à côté de ça tu as
l'économie des désirs
pas de d'éliminer mais c'est là tu peux
te dire bon bah tu laisses ça au marché
tu vois mais en revanche il y a une
organisation de la société pour que les
besoins c'était le système utility pour
information dans la deuxième guerre
mondiale l'Angleterre a fonctionné comme
ça avec un système utility qui
garantissait qu'un certain nombre de
besoins essentiels étaient remplis tout
ça rentrer dans l'utilité et puis il y
avait de façon marginale une économie
des désirs à côté on fait quand on a
toute une génération qui a été
programmée à coup de neuromarketing pour
activer les zones les plus primitives du
désir dans leur cerveau pour acheter des
conneries je suis désolé de parler aussi
vulgairement comment on fait pour se
battre et imposer un nouveau système
donc ça c'est la prochaine question mais
la première question c'était comment on
fait pour réindustrialiser un pays quand
on n'a pas d'énergie bon marché
d'abord il faut à l'intérieur de
réindustrialiser on doit se demander ce
qu'on veut produire est-ce qu'on ne veut
plus produire j'insiste tu vois plutôt
ce qu'on va pouvoir produire et pénurie
de machin de pièces de composants de
matériaux de matière première etc
disons-nous qu'il nous reste quand même
encore des marges manoeuvre et que là on
voit
semblement
la vraisemblablement aujourd'hui
l'énergie je veux dire on peut avoir de
l'énergie électrique encore on n'est pas
mort sur le sur ce terrain là
la moitié du parc est mort il est pas en
réparation mais il est pas mort mais
j'ai pas envie de me lancer dans un
débat souvenirs
et juste t'as pas le courage de venir te
[__] sur ce fauteuil à ma place c'est
en train de se faire c'est en train de
se faire va peut-être y avoir une
interview de Sky c'est par une brut une
brute que on voit jamais sa tête
d'ailleurs
revenons à nos moutons oui rien
industrialiser la France dans cinq ans
avec une énergie qui coûte un bras un
rein un œil avec des marchés alternatifs
qui coûtent un bras un rein un œil
le problème sur ton dada toi mon dada
c'est la physique et la calorie
donc tes chaussures c'est 500 calories
ton jean c'est 1800 calories petit à
chemise étant de calories ta montre
s'étendre calories ta coupe de cheveux
s'étend de calories
je pose c'est est-ce que on veut ou on
veut pas tu as par exemple je sur les
t-shirts
t-shirt français garantie 10 ans bravo
mais tu as des marques
de mode
pas celle de Pino et Arnaud mais
si on te dit nous ce qu'on veut ce qu'on
demande c'est être plus régulier parce
que si vous mettez pas de règle nous on
tente de vouloir faire des choses qui
soient à la fois locales qui soient
respectueuse de l'environnement qui soit
bien foutu et au fond si vous mettez pas
de règle et ben on est tué en permanence
par la fast fashion qui va chercher
sa production de t-shirt
posé mes questions comment on fait pour
réindustrialiser le pays avec une
énergie qui coûte un bras un oeil et un
rein mais d'abord tu te demandes ce que
ce que tu veux produire je suis désolé
mais il y a sans doute avant de vouloir
produire quoi que ce soit
on est d'accord que si on n'a pas
d'énergie bon marché on l'a dans l'os
mais non pourquoi bon marché je veux
dire elle sera pas bon marché bah oui tu
auras de l'énergie qui est pas bon
marché ok mais de la même manière que
moi je suis favorable parce qu'on est à
main d'oeuvre qui soit pas bon marché
donc pourquoi ça devrait pourquoi on
devrait fermer les frontières
fermez non mais je veux dire moi je suis
partisan de du protectionnisme oui donc
ça veut dire que je pense qu'il faut les
quotas il faut des taxes aux frontières
il faut des barrières douanières ça veut
pas dire qu'aujourd'hui on doit se dire
qu'on va relever de 20% les barrières
douanières sur tous les produits
importés non non ça n'aurait pas de sens
aujourd'hui il faut cibler ce qu'on veut
relocaliser mais il faut cibler alors tu
peux dire aliments vêtements médicament
par exemple mais tu tu dois cibler il y
a il y a 20 000 lignes tarifs
il y a 20 000 lignes tarifaires à l'OMC
alors Organisation Mondiale du Commerce
et bien dans ces 20 000 lignes
tarifaires là tu dois cibler ce qui te
paraît essentiel que tu dois
sur lequel tu dois retrouver une
certaine indépendance et ça se fait pas
tous azimut ça se fait en s'organisant
et en disant voilà je cible ces produits
là je veux ne plus dépendre sur les
principes actifs tu sais que il y a il y
a 20 ans on produisait 80 % des
principes actifs des médicaments ici et
20 % ailleurs et maintenant ça c'est
inversé c'est 80% ailleurs 20% ici si tu
veux inverser ça c'est là où je te dis
la question clé pour moi c'est le marché
ou la volonté si tu laisses faire parce
que moi ça fait 10 ans dans mon coin
c'est pour des raisons d'abord sociales
que je me suis bagarré là-dessus c'est
vrai
ça fait 10 ans même plus qu'on me dit il
y a de la relocalisation il va y avoir
de la relocalisation je la vois pas
venir moi je la vois pas venir
[Rires]
je suis pire que toi pour la simple et
bonne raison ça fait 10 ans qu'on fait
ça en des politiques des politiques des
politiques qu'on envoie beaucoup et
quand on leur parlait il y a 10 ans
d'énergie ils nous regardait comme des
poissons rouges là ils font moins les
malins là alors je veux dire moi je fais
5 ans au moins qu'en commission des
affaires économiques je te le dire sur
un autre truc d'accord c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs tu es ici laisse-moi
laisse-moi terminer tu vois là
aujourd'hui c'est comme si d'ailleurs
c'est lié aux questions d'énergie on
nous dit bah toute façon il va y avoir
un relèvement du prix des transports et
donc le relèvement pris des transports
va faire que naturellement on va
retrouver des marchandises qui vont être
produites à proximité c'est à dire que
c'est encore la main invisible du marché
qui va faire des miracles et nous
ramener ça ici non c'est pas vrai si on
le veut pas ça ne se produira pas donc
il faut le vouloir tu vois donc le prix
des transports qui se relève c'est lié à
ton énergie mais tu vois sur le marché
du travail moi ma bagarre c'est quoi
que Bernadette et Géraldine c'est que
c'était identifié dans un rapport je
prends la séquence la séquence dans
laquelle on se trouve c'est à dire tu as
la crise du covid la crise du covid elle
te montre quoi elle te montre le
caractère essentiel de Bernadette et
Géraldine à qui on a demandé de
continuer à bosser parce qu'il fallait
que les chambres d'hôpital elles soient
nettoyées on a demandé aux
aides-soignants de continuer à bosser on
a demandé aux caissières de continuer à
bosser on a demandé au manutentionnaires
de continuer à bosser on a demandé au
charisme
qu'on ne voit pas dans ton parle pas
d'habitude là les auxiliaires de vie
sociale et compagnie il fallait qu'elle
travaille et donc on ait votre travail
est essentiel vous êtes indispensable
c'était la phrase de Macron tu sais à
l'époque il disait il faudra se rappeler
que notre pays tout entier repose
aujourd'hui sur ces femmes et ses hommes
que nos économies reconnaissent ces
rémunères si mal et il a ajouté citant
la Déclaration universelle de 1789 les
distinctions sociales ne peuvent reposer
que sur l'utilité des communes tu vois
et je connais très bien ma contre gauche
dure 30 secondes mais bon et donc
dans la foulée de ça qu'est-ce qui est
décidé rien sinon un rapport tu peux
dire [__] rapport de plus je lis le
rapport rapport de la DARES donc le
ministère des affaires sociales et
rédigé par une économie qui s'appelle
christinael qui identifie 17 métiers de
la deuxième ligne que je viens de te
citer aussi et les ouvriers de
l'industrie alimentaire les travailleurs
du bâtiment tout ça 5 millions de
personnes 5 millions de personnes donc
ça vient nous dire ils sont sous-payés
ils ont des contrats courts ils ont des
horaires instables et ils ont plus de
pénibilité respirent des produits
chimiques et tout ça en revanche ils ont
un grand sentiment d'utilité mais donc
ça c'est le rapport académique qui est
vraiment formidable et quelle est la
conclusion politique quand il Elisabeth
borne qui était à l'époque ministre du
Travail c'est nous faisons le pari avec
confiance que le dialogue social
aboutira à quelque chose d'int
c'est à dire et ben finalement c'est la
main invisible du marché la rebaptiser
dialogue social une forme de Providence
qui va faire que l'atmonie va être
rétabli sur terre et que les salaires
des agents d'entretien ils vont grimper
de 30% enfin et rien ne s'est produit
tout ça les salaires de Géraldine c'est
le même ça n'a pas bougé même il s'est
gratté par l'inflation aujourd'hui donc
si on est à combien si pour ça en gros
ça c'est celle qui a annoncé je pense
que tu as des influences différentielles
c'est à dire que
si tu es dans les classes pop tu
conseilles
consacre plus de part de ton revenu à
manger par exemple on sait qu'il y a
plus d'inflation sur la bouffe donc et
si tu es à la campagne tu as plus de
dépenses en matière de chauffage et en
matière de déplacement et donc tu vas
avoir plus à payer une inflation qui va
être plus importante aussi là dessus de
toute façon l'inflation elle pèse
surtout sur ceux qui dépensent et pas
sur ceux qui épargne sur ce épargne ça
pèse moins dans les dépenses courantes
mais bon qu'importe maintenant tu vois
le je pense que le grand choix il est
entre la volonté là si tu veux qu'il
soit révalué tous ces métiers là ça va
pas se faire par le fruit du hasard ça
se fera parce qu'on le voudra ou alors
est-ce que tu l'as faire le marché et
je vais je vais encore faire mon relou
l'énergie donc augmentation des salaires
tu 30%
30% de la même manière que je te dis que
on
identifie quel produit on veut rapatrier
dans les 20 000 lignes tarifs de valides
tarifaire de l'OMC de la même manière on
identifie dans les métiers lesquels on
veut réévaluer et il s'agit pas de de
réévaluer plus Hitler parce que c'était
ta question là ta question c'était sur
l'industrialisation de France comment on
fait avec des gars qui ont un imaginaire
où on active leurs zones de désir en
permanence comment on fait pour changer
ça et je pense qu'on changera pas
pourquoi j'ai fait journaliste moi j'ai
fait journaliste parce que je me suis
dit
pas vraiment
de mes revenus quand j'étais journaliste
à fakir il y avait peu de risques la
niche fiscale me servent à quoi que ce
soit mais parce que je me disais que je
voulais changer le monde
[Musique]
dans les corps dans les c'est dur de
prétendre ayer donc évidemment il faut
couper ça ouais ça veut dire que
franchement il faut rompre avec la
publicité partout tout le temps si tu
veux vraiment sortir
de
d'une hyperconsommation qu'on peut plus
permettre sur le plan écologique mais de
toute façon qui est déjà à mon avis
déprimante sur le plan humain
on en revient à l'énergie je veux pas
cacher donc là on nous annonce que si le
gaz russe il est il est coupé
définitivement on va ressortir de
l'hiver au mois de février donc en
février on sera toujours en hiver on
ressortira entre 5% et 20% de nos stocks
de gaz d'accord comment on va faire pour
le refaire nos stocks de gaz et comment
on va faire pour trouver des
fournisseurs alternatifs est-ce que là
il y a eu la rentrée des députés
ils seront courantes tout ça ils
maîtrise de qui peut nous fournir du gaz
qui peut avoir des marchés parallèles
qui ont des marchés alternatifs où ils
sont juste là pour faire un pot de fleur
je sais pas s'ils sont là pour faire les
fondamentaux est-ce qu'ils sont courants
de d'autres choses aussi mais les
fondamentaux énergétiques t'as pas
d'énergie tu allumes pas ton énergie tu
peux te dire que
les gens sont soignés dans la manière
dont les gens sont éduqués ça fait
partie quand même de fondamentaux aussi
sans énergie
mais
donc de toute façon
j'ai ma question est-ce qu'ils sont au
courant de ça de toute façon je veux
dire nous nous faisons pas d'illusions
sur l'assemblée doit d'abord c'est pas
là que se trouve le lieu de pouvoir
c'est où le pouvoir il y a l'Élysée au
moins on est dans un pays où c'est clair
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans notre pays
les lois sont décidées par l'Elysée
elles sont fabriquées technocratiquement
par les ministères elles sont
enregistrées à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est ce que un grand
constitualiste jean-chose connard
appelle le temps de l'habillage
démocratique en fait tu sers à rien non
je pense pas à ça tu vois je pense que
on a une fonction qui n'est pas la
fonction législative je pense que grosso
modo c'est du flan on l'a alors
évidemment on a une chambre qui est un
peu plus incertaine par les temps qui
courent mais quand même il y aura des
magies majorités qui se dégagent mais en
revanche on est le lieu de
d'une fonction tribunicienne alors tu
sais le tribun du peuple c'était celui
qui est du temps des Romains était
envoyé par les quartiers populaires pour
aller chahuter le Sénat des aristocrates
tu vois et ben je pense que je remplis
une fonction tribunicienne c'est-à-dire
d'interpellation sur
ben voilà tu vois hier je parlais de
Cindy excuse-moi mais je fais mon truc
qui est assistante maternelle qui a
travaillé pendant la crise de covid
alors que pour prendre les gamins des
soignants alors qu'elle est en obésité
et que donc elle avait des angoisses sur
qu'est-ce que ça allait lui faire le
virus avec le protocole le nettoyage
dans tous les sens elle a fait le boulot
et ça a l'air de misère pour oui pour le
SMIC quoi grosso modo elle a sorti de la
crise covid bon il faudra se rappeler
que notre pays tout entier rien du tout
tu vois au contraire là les réformes du
chômage elle fait que elle perde deux
gamins elle a pas de droit au chômage
qu'est-ce que c'est les conséquences
pour elle bah c'est plus légumes au
marché plus de viande rouge les gamins
qui sont qui vont plus à la cantine le
midi et elle qui fait pas d'activité
Zumba tu vois qui se prive sur à la fois
des choses
[Musique]
superficielle on va dire mais où on peut
avoir du bien-être et sur des choses qui
sont un peu plus un peu plus
essentielles bon bah voilà l'activité
Zumba tu connais pas la zumba
c'était déjà la torture
donc nous voilà ça me fait penser à un
truc tu vois non non sur
[Musique]
ta question de l'énergie mais sur où
est-ce qu'on pense que se trouve le
progrès
tu vois au fond pendant et Dieu il en
pense quoi
non pendant un siècle au fond il y a eu
une équivalence entre plus égal mieux
tu vois on mangeait plus donc c'était
mieux
plus d'énergie c'était mieux et tu avais
un lien entre le PIB et les indices de
bien-être en fait jusqu'au milieu des
années 70 un lien une corrélation entre
l'espérance de vie le taux de mortalité
infantile enfin elle choque petroïde
parce que finalement le PIB depuis un
autre rythme mais il a continué de
croître tu vois et en revanche ces
indices de bien-être eux ont stagné
qu'est-ce qui se passe et je pense que
il faut regarder dans l'époque aussi les
signes qui peuvent être positifs pour ce
qu'on la société qu'on veut construire
parce qu'on peut pas être seulement en
description d'une société qui serait
juste dans on doit résister le moins le
moins le moins tu vois qu'est-ce qui se
passe à partir de ce moment-là c'est
qu'au fond quand les gens ils ont un
frigo qu'on leur en mettre un deuxième
ça produire pas une joie immense que
quand ils ont à bouffé une fois c'est
pas la peine de mettre deux fois plus de
bouffe sur la table tu comprends le truc
et donc à ce moment là il y a une
décorrélation entre le plus et le mieux
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que dès
lors le progrès est-ce qu'il continue à
se trouver dans les biens les biens
matériels dans
là le téléphone avec la 6G connecté au
frigo qui prévient Carrefour Market
quand il y a plus d'olives à l'intérieur
et en gros c'est le progrès qui nous
vende c'est ce progrès là ou alors on
pense que les le progrès maintenant il
est au éolien c'est à dire la qualité
des relations du soin de
l'accompagnement qu'on a pour nos bébés
nos enfants qui soient accompagnés
handicapés ou pas nos ados et jusque nos
personnes âgées de la naissance à la
mort et attends je termine ça veut dire
si tu arrives à produire faire se
basculement du progrès se basculement
idéologique quelque part de se dire
voilà quel est le sens de l'existence
est-ce que c'est l'accumulation de bien
ou c'est les meilleurs liens tu bascules
aussi d'une société qui est hyper
consommatrice de matière et d'énergie à
une société qui le dieu vient moi tu
vois et donc c'est pour ça que moi tu
sais que j'ai fait un film qui s'appelle
debout les femmes j'ai fait une mission
parlementaire sur ce que j'ai appelé les
métiers du lien parce que je considère
que c'est une triple cause à travers ça
c'est une cause féministe évidemment
puisque c'est 85 90 95% Bernadette
giraldine des femmes qui font ces
métiers là c'est une cause sociale parce
que c'est des centaines de milliers de
personnes sinon des millions que tu peux
faire sortir de la pauvreté alors
qu'elle travaille et pour moi c'est une
cause écologique parce que ça pose la
question du progrès et d'un basculement
de bien matériel vers des liens qui sont
peut-être plus spirituel quoi
donc ce basculement vers le spirituel
inch'Allah
se basculement quant à une inertie d'une
société qui a des problèmes intrigués
voire inextricable comment tu fais par
exemple pour dire aux gens bon
maintenant on va arrêter de consommer et
quand sur un fond d'investissement les
titres d'une certaine boîte font partie
d'un portefeuille qui permet de garantir
la retraite à certaines personnes
comment on fait pour
désintriguer démêler tout ça pour
revenir à un système plus simple ou
est-ce qu'on va vers un effondrement qui
va ensuite être un événement exotique
extérieur et fédérateur
pour faire basculer ça dans la tête des
gens moi je ne fais jamais la politique
du pire c'est quoi la politique du pire
la politique du pire ça serait le pari
mais que j'ai déjà entendu que
finalement laissons faire les sons
s'installer la misère il va y avoir
tellement de misère que ça va produire
une révolte et que la société va se
remettre sur ses pieds tu vois par
exemple ou sur ses pieds sur une
consommation énergétique exponentielle
même au-delà de ce facteur au-delà de ce
facteur donc du coup que d'un
effondrement naitrait une résurrection
d'une société harmonieuse
je ne fais jamais le pari du pire
d'accord donc
ensuite comment on fait sur les
retraites déjà les retraites tu sais
qu'il y a une bagarre qui est en cours
ah bah oui mais pour que ça soit pas
que ça soit pas par des fonds de pension
et de la capitalisation mais que ça
reste une solidarité entre les
générations et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut faire persister évidemment
c'est quand je disais tu vois la prise
local d'intérêt il faut se rendre compte
que dans le pays il reste deux trésors
gigantesques dont les rapaces alors
manipulera pas parce que finalement il
faut les protéger les rapaces mais les
prédateurs
financiers tournent autour tu vois et
c'est la santé
et c'est la retraite ou là il y a de la
possibilité que ça soit par dizaines
sinon centaines de milliards que ça soit
récupéré et à passer du public ou de la
solidarité nationale de la Solidarité
sociale à la concurrence des fonds
privés donc voilà donc là on se mégarde
déjà dessus te dire que je vais te
mettre d'autres points qui sont pour moi
positifs je veux voir les les ferments
de possibles qu'on a tu vois je t'ai
décrit le le processus
avec Huntington de l'apathie politique
de l'installation de la mondialisation
pour faire changer la peur de quand qui
produit de la résignation qui produit de
l'abattement qui produit découragement
et que moi tu sais je peux constater
dans ma région porte à préporte tu vois
mais te dire aussi le moment que nous
vivons et qui explique quelque part
la violence du pouvoir
c'est grammes chies qui parlent donc
communiste italien enfermé en prison
dans les années 20 par le régime
musulman qui parle à ce moment-là d'un
détachement de l'idéologie dominante tu
vois et il dit dans les moments de
détachement de l'idéologie dominante et
je pense que nous en vivons ça veut dire
que les mots croisés concurrence
mondialisation qui en gros le triptyque
du pouvoir depuis 40 ans
qui est un triptyque dans lequel ils ont
pu entraîner un moment par l'envie c'est
les 80 Reggane satcheurs Yves Montand
vive la crise avec Bernard Tapie
l'entreprise magique la mondialisation
heureuse à la main que tu vois tout ça
aujourd'hui ces mots-là concurrence
mondialisation ce sont des mots qui
dégoûtent et qui inquiètent donc c'est
un détachement de l'idéologie de
dominante et nous dit ramechi dans ces
moments-là qu'est-ce qui se passe et
bien comme les gouvernants n'arrivent
plus
à gouverner à diriger ils font appel à
la force de coercition donc
en fait c'est à la fois la force
coutumière quotidienne de la résignation
qui demeure la principale des forces il
faut que les gens se résignent tant que
les gens n'ont pas une lueur d'espérance
qui s'allume c'est bon le système est
tranquille mais quand elle s'allume type
gilet jaune qu'est-ce qui se passe là on
fait intervenir la force de coercition
tu vois et donc au fond ça fait un
paquet d'années maintenant que les
dirigeants savent que il faut qu'ils
continuent à faire la même chose hors
démocratie pourquoi tu as le traité
consignateur européen en a été une
illustration
mais ça c'est un exemple
ou la démocratie s'est fait Fuller au
pied
précisément que là juste j'ouvre une
parenthèse
tu as suivi un peu ce qui s'est passé en
Italie bah oui bon et quand tu as Ursula
attention les Italiens si vous votez mal
on a des outils pour vous faire bien
passer la pilule tu as entendu c'était
pas c'était pas textuellement ça
qu'on en pense qu'on en pense par
rapport au voie italiens est-ce que
c'est un Ursula de faire des menaces non
d'abord d'une part c'est pas moi je suis
pour que les peuples se déterminent
c'est à eux de décider leur destin point
barre ça te plaît ou ça te plaît pas
mais c'est au peuple de décider de son
destin et même quand le résultat te
plaît pas et deuxièmement je pense que
c'est complètement contre-productif
quant à une autorité extérieure qui dit
votez bien qu'est-ce que tu as envie de
faire tu as envie de lui faire un bras
d'honneur tu vois je veux dire et de la
même manière dans là c'est pas l'extrême
droite mais quand ça a été la gauche en
Grèce en Grèce avec Syriza qui arrivait
au pouvoir du temps où s'y passe avait
pas déjà basculé je veux dire c'est
François Hollande qui apparaît au
journal télévisé grec pour dire
attention votez bien sinon ça va mal se
passer
alors c'est une erreur historique parce
qu'évidemment François Hollande
qu'est-ce qu'il aurait dû espérer que ça
soit sipras qui arrive au pouvoir ça
c'était au moment où une élection qu'il
a finalement perdue et que en s'appuyant
sur votre suprace en Grèce mais même sur
des gouvernements de droite à l'époque
en Espagne
au Portugal ou en Italie le 1er geste de
François Hollande élu aurait dû être de
faire une tournée des capitales du Sud
pour aller construire et devenir le fer
de lance le leader la locomotive d'une
Europe du Sud qui vient bousculer
l'Europe du Nord et à la place de ça il
est allé négocier la couture sur le sur
le pantalon tout seul face à Berlin et
il est comme un petit élève finalement
le pacte qui devait valider qui avait
été signé par Sarkozy et Merkel et bien
il a pleinement validé ce qui a été au
fond la trahison initiale mais qui
qui disait tout ce que serait son mandat
puisque il se liait les mains à ce
moment-là mais c'est une parenthèse que
tu me fais ouvrir et que du coup me fait
oublier où est-ce qu'on en était alors
que j'avais des choses passionnantes à
raconter voilà la France non non
on en était où là avant tu parlais de
Bernadette non non
l'idéologie dominante je te dis fin
voilà
dis-toi bien
là tu as je te dis très très conscien
européen d'accord
55% des Français votent non mais 80% des
ouvriers 71% des chômeurs 67% des
employés donc tu as un véritable vote de
classe et par ailleurs ils savent
maintenant qu'ils ne repasseront jamais
un texte de cette nature là sur la
concurrence libre réunion fossé sur la
livreur circulation des capitaux et des
marchands y compris avec les pays tiers
devant les gens pourquoi parce que le
résultat ce sera pas 55%, ça sera 60%
65%
70%, ça sera une défaite massive donc
depuis ce moment là ils savent qu'ils
veulent continuer à mener la même
politique mais sans le peuple voire
contre le peuple regarde un mot que tu
peux surveiller c'est le mot courage
continue d'utiliser dans la langue des
Macron et compagnie ou de la langue des
éditorialistes c'est jamais le courage
d'aller affronter les puissances
financières c'est jamais le courage
d'aller
mettre de l'ordre dans les
multinationales jamais ce courage là
c'est toujours place une seconde c'est
les réformes courageuses c'est toujours
pour dire c'est sur les gens on va voir
le courage d'aller fort faire des
réformes qui sont contre les gens alors
là on a une panoplie de réforme
courageuse qui est à venir sur les
retraites le chômage et ainsi de suite
on a beaucoup de réformes courageuses
mais toujours dans ce même sens du mot
courage et tu vois
se dire parce que c'était vraiment un
ferment que au fond si on avait laissé
décider les
est-ce que tu crois qu'il serait allé
signer des traités d'accord du Gat
de l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
pour opérer ce grand déménagement du
monde jamais tu vois si jamais on avait
demandé aux gens mais si on avait
demandé aux gens est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour que les usines elles
délocalisent comme ça jamais ils
auraient accepté est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour respecter le déficit à 3%
et que on ferme des lits tous les ans
sur les hôpitaux jamais ils auraient
accepté tu vois les milliers de vie et
on continue là bon et donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que pas seulement le
jour du vote 29 mai 2005 sur le traité
constitution européen mais de manière
ordinaire des tas de décision dans la
démocratie se prennent contre les gens
sans les gens évidemment mais même si on
sait que c'est contre
je regarde alors il y a des grands
moments politiques qui montrent cette
tension nuit debout pour les
centres-villes des jeunes éduqués mais
les gilets jaunes pour les classes
populaires de la défense périphériques
aussi les gilets jaunes oui oui alors
avec des métiers qui sont plutôt des
métiers dominés bien souvent bon les
métiers de la deuxième ligne typiquement
bon mais tu as des choses que je regarde
comme étant de l'Infra politique qui
montre que sous nos pieds il y a un
désir d'autre chose
on demande aux gens quelle maison vous
voulez
bon c'est et les gens très massivement y
répondre moi je veux une maison avec un
jardin je veux un cocon familial et ce
qui arrive dans tout dernier c'est une
maison high-tech connectée et pourtant
si on laisse faire le système qu'est-ce
qui prévoit eux et ben ils prévoient que
ton fauteuil demain il sera connecté
c'est ce qu'ils veulent tu vois tu
parles de dépenses d'énergie ils ont
fait la 5G on sait que la 5G c'est de la
consommation d'énergie supplémentaire et
ça leur posait pas de problème c'était
il y a deux ans tu vois comment on
essaie quand même un poisson rouge dans
un bocal il fait un tour on serait
supposé oublié leur décision de la
veille mais c'est marqué dans des textes
leur objectif c'est que 99% des objets
dans les maisons soient désormais
connectés bon mais quand on demande aux
gens est-ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
ralentir ou qu'il faut accélérer et
c'est lié à aller et c'est lié à
l'énergie puisque c'est ton tonitmotiv
parce que l'accélération c'est
évidemment la nécessité de vous êtes
dans une dépense et une surdépense
d'énergie pour accélérer et bien tu as
les deux tiers des Français qui
répondent nous on veut ralentir on
trouve que le monde va trop vite alors
que le système qu'est-ce qui va faire et
même ça mettre mot de la macronie
accélération accélération accélération
mais il y a pas de frein mais nous on
peut avoir des freins quel type de frein
je pense qu'on peut on peut décider que
comment on fait pour freiner 2200 2500
milliards de dettes on fait comment
alors je te disais est-ce que tu t'es
déjà mis à la place des macronistes non
j'ai pas vraiment envie
me mets dans ma tête dans un ministère
en me disant c'est comme ça que je
transformais les choses oui mais me
demande pas quand même de me mettre dans
la peau des Macron c'est important non
déjà pour le respect
total toujours et il a bienveillance
la bienveillance typiquement c'est quand
même un mot qui est un beau mot
mais il nous faut être bienveillant les
uns avec les autres mais qu'ils ont sali
parce que quand la bienveillance ça se
traduit par des bras arrachés des yeux
éborniers et des crânes fendus bonjour
la bienveillance ça s'appelle des
techniques de contre-insurrection digne
des pays du tiers-monde ça s'appelle pas
de la bienveillance
revenons à l'empathie si le macroniste
il va voir les marchés les marchés de la
finance la finance internationale il dit
écoute maintenant tu es bien gentil que
tu vas arrêter tes conneries
l'autre le fond vautour il va le
regarder il veut lui dire fais pas trop
ton malin parce que je vais attaquer ta
dette
puis tu vas être obligé d'augmenter tes
impôts puis après tu vas gérer la bande
d'hier Sud qui va vouloir te demander
des comptes
est-ce que c'est peut-être la voix de la
facilité de demander l'effort le courage
au premier lignes
mais je me mets pas à la place des
macrony parce que je pense que de me la
même manière que François Hollande avait
dit mon adversaire sur la finance mais
il y a pas eu une tentative de combat
ou de transformation je te dis avec
franchise que
François Hollande oui au deuxième tour
oui mais que
mais j'ai pas fait la fête le soir et
j'avais distribué des trucs où Emmanuel
Macron
je savais pas qu'elle élection bon mais
donc je distribuais pour Hollande des
tracts pendant la campagne et y compris
je l'avais mis sous forme de bande
dessinée en disant si jamais ça sort pas
dehors il y a rien qui se passera tu
vois c'est le Front populaire c'est les
victoires dans les urnes mais il faut
que ça bouge dans la rue sinon si on se
coupe pas le côté ça
la force est pas là quoi mais donc sur
ce que si demain nous obtenons le
pouvoir
franchement ça va être ju-jitsu tous les
jours quoi c'est sûr c'est sûr et je ne
te dis pas qu'il y aura la moindre chose
évidente maintenant puisque je te citais
Roosevelt au début il disait le pays ne
nous en voudra pas d'avoir essayé et
échouer mais nous en vendrez de ne pas
avoir essayé et je pense que il y a la
nécessité aujourd'hui d'essayer quelque
chose est-ce que je vois là c'est que
rien n'est essayé et ça fait 40 ans pour
moi qu'on a rien essayé pourquoi
pourquoi par d'abord parce que le
pouvoir il est passé il est entre les
mains de d'une classe qui n'a vraiment
pas intérêt à essayer mais à changer les
choses je veux dire que je t'ai décris
quand même
44 milliards d'euros de dividende cette
année il y a ça je n'a jamais été aussi
élevé mais ta ligne C qui nous dit que
le taux de marge des entreprises n'a
jamais été aussi important depuis la
création de son indice en 1949 tu vois
alors maintenant quand des entreprises
il faudrait vraiment regarder qui gagne
quoi à l'intérieur parce que pour
revenir à ta question d'énergie le le la
valeur ajoutée des entreprises d'énergie
et de transport parce que faudrait dire
c'est j'aime aussi tu vois les
porte-conteneurs c'est passé de 3% du
PIB à 6% du PIB c'est une captation de
richesse phénoménale et c'est pour ça
que moi je pense que même dans l'intérêt
du capitalisme Bruno Le Maire Emmanuel
Macron il devrait veiller à cette
distorsion énorme qui fait que tu as une
préemption de la valeur ajoutée qui est
considérable et qui évidemment touche
les salariés mais qui touchent aussi le
reste des entreprises et tu vois alors
j'en viens autre chose mais la gauche
traditionnellement c'est la répartition
capital travail à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise
tu as la bagarre sur
à qui valait richesses bon avec un
basculement de 10 points de la valeur
ajoutée du du travail vers le capital
notamment dans les années 80 aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il faut y ajouter une
deuxième chose de manière importante
c'est la répartition de la valeur
ajoutée à l'intérieur de la chaîne des
entreprises parce que tu regardes ce qui
se passe dans le bâtiment ou dans
d'autres choses mais tu as un grand
donneur d'Orne Bouygues et Fage Vinci
qui fait appel à un sous-traitant un
sous sous-traitant un chouchou traitant
un chouchou traitant avec
six niveaux comme ça et avec à la fin
des auto-entrepreneurs mais il y a plus
rien à partager il y a plus de mie à ta
partager donc évidemment il nous faut
penser comment les hyper profits qui
s'accumulent au sommet de la chaîne et
Ben sont répartis non seulement parmi
les ouvriers les salariés de Bouygues et
Vinci mais aussi dans toute la chaîne de
production
tout ça je te dis pas que ça va être
évident c'est pas c'est pas simple mais
ça fait 40 ans qu'on n'a pas essayé
parce que regarde Macron comment il est
élu quoi
Macron il est élu parce qu'il y a un
premier tour de l'élection qui se
déroule dans des appartements comme
celui-ci
tu fais les yeux non mais voilà oui
viens une semaine une fois par semaine
bouffer avec Bernard rannault ces
documenté
très bonne réponse
c'est pas comme si j'avais pas demandé
d'être invité mais
où ils rendent des services à Bouygues
tu vois on parlait de Alstom tout à
l'heure le fait qu'on file Alstom à
General électrique c'est Bouygues qui
ramasse des milliards de profits au
passage dans cette vente là et alors et
alors ça veut dire que à partir du
moment où il est adoubé par Bouygues
Niel dry Arnaud Bolloré Lagardère tu
vois ils sont 6
ça lui donne évidemment une puissance
médiatique considérable et derrière une
fois qu'il est à l'Élysée à qui doit
rendre des comptes en premier d'après
toi
est-ce que c'est au peuple français ou
ce qui est l'intérêt des financiers
pourquoi une réforme comme la
suppression de l'impôt sur solidarité
sur la fortune va être faite aussi
rapidement parce qu'il y a un accès
direct des grands patrons l'a fait en
l'occurrence à l'Elysée pour aller
imposer les mesures tu vois donc ça a
quand même ça a des conséquences donc ça
fait mais alors là où je veux te donner
encore une note positive c'est que
au fond pendant 40 ans
le bloc libéral il avait les moyens de
se diviser tu vois entre une droite
libérale et une gauche libérale et de
produire une fausse alternance entre les
deux au fond comme ce que je t'ai décrit
tout à l'heure le détachement d'une
idéologie dominante est-elle ce bloc
central c'est réduit
donc il a fallu qui n'est plus qu'un
candidat unique parce que sinon il y
avait un risque que la victoire ailleurs
tu vois et je pense que ce processus
d'effritement qui va pas être un
effondrement du bloc libéral mais ce
processus d'effritement du bloc central
va se poursuivre et donc la grande
question elle est ouverte la force des
tentation est-ce que ça va être dans de
l'autorité est-ce que c'est ça c'est ça
la réponse à ma question où va la France
c'est une réponse et je disais en
démarrant l'émission que il n'y a pas de
fatalité pour moi il y a une fatalité
quand tu as plus d'énergie
quand tu es sur l'autoroute Quand tu es
dans ta R18 et que tu peux faire un coup
de démarreur et que ça démarre pas tu
restes avec tes R18 sur l'autoroute
il y a plus d'énergie bon marché il y a
plus d'énergie ben il y a de l'énergie
cher d'accord maintenant est-ce que
cette énergie chère on décide qu'elle
est
répandue selon la main invisible du
marché comme à l'échelle ça veut dire ce
que ceux qui ont des jets et ceux qui
ont des yachts ils auront les moyens de
remplir leur jet et leur yacht pour eux
ça sera presque indolore tu vois cette
hausse là si tu laisses faire le marché
voilà ce qui va se passer
ou alors est-ce que tu décides
d'organiser l'énergie que tu as tu vois
et à ce moment là de choisir la
répartition qui te paraît la plus juste
au sein de la société comment on va
répartir ça
s'agit de se dire quels sont les besoins
fondamentaux qu'on souhaite remplir tu
vois est-ce que c'est quand les piscines
ont fermé mais là on arrive à un moment
où c'est pas qu'on souhaite remplir
c'est qu'on peut se permettre
ce qu'on peut se permettre s'il y a une
réduction des derniers quels sont les
choix qu'opèrent la société qu'est-ce
qui lui paraît primordial qu'est-ce qui
lui paraît pas primordial tu as le fait
que les piscines ferment
ça peut être interrogé mais en revanche
ce n'est pas l'actionnaire des piscines
ont décidé ça n'est pas la main
invisible de du marché dans décidé ça
doit être décidé collectivement que ça
ne nous paraît plus comme un besoin
essentiel mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que franchement il va falloir
passer non pas à la main visible du
marché à une relèvement des coûts mais à
des planchers et des plafonds avec une
interdiction de consommer plus que une
certaine dose d'énergie par personne je
te donne un autre truc pour essayer de
te faire rebondir
une calorie assimilée c'est entre 7 à 10
calories d'énergie fossile
est-ce que tu comprends cette phrase
plus ou moins vas-y donc
ta tomate produit sous serre avec très
peu d'oligo-éléments de valeurs
nutritives où il y a que de la flotte
dedans
quand tu vas l'assimiler ça veut dire
que derrière tu as ton transporteur les
lumières dans la serre le chauffage de
la serre ainsi de suite
quand on prie de l'énergie augmente
ta calories que tu vas assimiler elle
augmente aussi tu comprends
comment on fait pour se positionner dans
une démocratie si ça n'est pas un épi
phénomène dû à notre consommation
énergétique
c'est-à-dire qu'on a eu de l'énergie
facile en consommation exponentielle
depuis à peu près 2000 ans
est-ce que la démocratie c'est pas un
épiphénomène en fait est-ce que la
démocratie les soins les médicaments la
petite voiture la maison à la campagne
de petits jardins en fait c'était
simplement une parenthèse historique et
que là
l'équilibrage naturel de l'énergie est
en train de nous rappeler que ça
consomme peut-être trop d'énergie et la
démocratie est-ce que je me trompe
la démocratie et la consommation
d'énergie
le lien entre la démocratie et la
consommation d'énergie est-ce que le
fait que en gros là tu il y a déjà un
tas d'intellectuels réac qui aujourd'hui
sortent ce truc là c'est que Georges
Steiner James Lovelock bon qui te dise
en gros il nous faut passer à despotisme
libéral parce que il y a que moi ou pas
oui mais
théocratie de parce qu'il y a une crise
écologique et donc la réponse à la crise
écologique ça doit être une forme de
despotisme libéral tu vois alors des
énergétique c'est la même chose que la
crise écologique je pense qu'il y a un
lien entre les deux oui il y a un lien
entre les deux bon donc et moi je te dis
que on a le choix on a le choix
d'organiser ou pas la société on a la
choix de la laisser dériver ou de
se dire que ensemble on doit décider
qui nous paraît primordial et ce qui
nous paraît pas primordial et en
l'occurrence que les gens puissent se
nourrir me paraît primordial maintenant
tu parles de tomates sous serre
normalement il y a un truc qui fait de
la synthèse qui s'appelle le soleil et
qui est pas forcément les luminaires
allumés dans dans les serres tu vois
donc c'est du coup quel comment on
transforme l'agriculture mais
sans engrais bon marché
ça veut dire que des sols affaiblis qui
mettront 5 ans si tu si tu choisis de
regarder que tout ce qu'il y a de plus
terrible et tout ça c'est sûr
je ne choisis pas de regarder tout ce
qu'il y a de plus terrible je ne suis
pas un politique et je regarde les sols
les les choses en face
il y a le choix de dire tout va mal tout
va aller encore plus mal tout va aller
encore plus vous inquiétez pas votez
pour moi ça ira mieux demain
vous inquiétez pas parce que moi je suis
fait d'inquiétude mais je te dis
maintenant soit on se dit que bah voilà
de toute façon le pire va devenir je
reformule ma question est-ce que tu
organises la société ou que tu canalise
la chute
mais la chute
il peut y avoir diminution sans que ça
soit une chute
oui il peut y avoir c'est quoi c'est la
croissance négative c'est ça il peut y
avoir une diminution de il y a un
certain nombre de choses que que si on
le diminue notre notre organisation
quotidienne on n'en sera pas plus
malheureux et il faut ce que je te
disais tout à l'heure c'est un certain
nombre de bien matériels qui peuvent
être nettement diminués pour moi et un
certain nombre de liens spirituels qui
peut être peuvent être nettement
renforcés et si tu regardes
l'agriculture par exemple c'est évident
que c'est pas la main invisible du
marché avec le choix qui est bien
conduisait dit que c'était une folie de
déléguer à notre notre alimentation et
notre production citation d'Emmanuel
Macron pendant la crise covid et qu'il a
signe des accords de libre échange non
seulement avec le Canada non seulement
avec le Mexique non seulement avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande mais veut en signer
aussi avec le Mercosur pour opérer en
matière d'agriculture un hypermarché
mondial bon bah c'est pas comme ça qu'on
va transformer notre agriculture ici
mais de la même manière tu vois sur le
bâtiment qui est parce que je recevais
les gens de chez enedis chez moi
ou RTE je sais plus mais enfin ta
cuisine non non ma permanence
parlementaire bon et donc bon ils me
font la description il va y avoir besoin
de plus d'électricité demain donc il va
y avoir
soit des centrales soit des
je sais plus ce qu'ils veulent installer
mais éoliennes en mer soit les deux qui
vont être installés en Normandie et qui
ça doit passer par la Picardie pour
aller nourrir le Nord-Pas-de-Calais quoi
bon donc je m'explique ça je mets sur
quoi on peut réduire
la consommation le premier truc qui
sorte c'est le logement et c'est
l'évidence moi ça fait cinq ans qu'en
commission des Affaires d'économiques je
dis que il nous faut un grand plan
contre les passoires thermiques parce
que ça sera du gagnant gagnant-gagnant
gagnant ça sera du gagnant pour les
factures des gens ça sera du gagnant
pour l'emploi local ça sera avec du
gagnant pour la planète ça sera gagnant
pour l'indépendance du prix parce qu'on
soit moins dépendant du fiol du fioul ou
du gaz importé bon jusqu'à maintenant il
s'en avait rien à [__] d'ailleurs
l'année dernière tu sais combien la
rénover de passent sur thermique je vais
faire un peu mon quiz combien de pasteur
thermique on a des rénover l'année dans
quelle région en France
2500 pour être exact et avec ou sans
coup d'augmentation des matières
premières avec mais bon ça veut dire
tiennent pas une semaine et que tu tapes
40 % d'augmentation il y en a 5 millions
de patients thermiques ça veut dire que
ce rythme là on en a pour 2000 ans on en
a pour l'équivalent entre le Christ
aujourd'hui donc si tu laisses faire la
main invisible du marché le avec un
petit peu de prime rénov au milieu voilà
le résultat c'est juste pour changer les
fenêtres ou pour faire les quatre murs
tu sais c'est pour généralement pour un
acte dans ta maison et non pas pour la
totalité la rénovation donc
donc c'est pour ça qu'on aura que 2500
mais donc là soit tu laisses faire ça
soit tu te dis c'est une priorité si
c'est une priorité c'est des dizaines de
milliards d'euros que tu mets à
l'intérieur alors auparavant il disait
mais non mais ça va pas la tête et tout
ça maintenant il me disent de toute
façon on n'a pas les travailleurs pour
faire ça mais c'est pareil ils attendent
la main invisible du marché pour que les
travailleurs ils existent tu sais de la
même manière qu'on a des publicités à la
télé pour l'armée ou on te dit allez
servir votre pays partez à l'autre bout
du monde je pense qu'il nous faudrait
des publicités à la télé pour dire
aider la planète et des votes pays
entrer dans les métiers du bâtiment tu
vois profite tu me fais une passerelle
chez nous chez nous il y a pas de
publicité on prend pas l'argent de
Google donc n'hésitez pas à nous mettre
la pièce sur tipee et y compris c'est un
message qui vaut à ceux qui nous
écoutent sur podcast parce qu'il voit
pas le bandeau défilé à l'écran donc
allez sur tipee pour nous soutenir parce
que chez nous il la pub je te laisse
continuer c'était vraiment la balle au
milieu et donc un tu fais la pub là en
l'occurrence pour les travailleurs du
bâtiment pour tu vois et ça rejoint
quelque chose que tu veux pas aborder
parce que toi ton truc c'est l'énergie
énergétique mais pour moi qui ai le
soustabilité des fondamentaux de
soutenir notre société qui est le
travail et la transformation à venir
face au défi climatique aussi par le
travail bon et
ne la même manière que aujourd'hui ces
métiers là si tu considères que ce sont
des métiers essentiels t'attends pas que
ça soit le marché qui relève les
salaires tu dis c'est 2000 euros minimum
c'est une semaine de congés payés
supplémentaire par an parce que c'est
des métiers qui sont durs et c'est à 50
ans la possibilité d'une deuxième
carrière comme pour les militaires si
jamais tu as le dos qui en vrac à 50 ans
mais de la même manière que pour
l'énergie tu décides qu'est-ce qui est
prioritaire pour l'énergie
tu dois te demander mais qu'est-ce qui
est probioritaire pour la main d'oeuvre
où est-ce qu'elle doit aller qu'est-ce
qui est probioritaire pour les
savoir-faire qu'est-ce qui est
prioritaire pour les capitaux vers quoi
en canalise c'est Roosevelt dans la
deuxième guerre mondiale il ne
nationalise pas tout en revanche il
canalise il dirige il oriente de la même
manière aujourd'hui on devrait
diriger canaliser orienté les
savoir-faire l'énergie les capitaux la
main d'oeuvre vers ce qui nous paraît le
plus essentiel et
beaucoup moins sur le reste tu parlais
des militaires
on a entendu hier nous sommes en guerre
est-ce que vous les députés vous avez
été consultés par l'Elysée sur les
sanctions sur les exports d'armes sur le
fait qu'il y ait des soldats à nous des
gens de chez nous qui se baladent sur le
terrain est-ce que vous avez été
consulté consultez oui un vote non
d'accord vous a juste dit on va parler
et donc un vote non je crois pas qu'il y
a une votes sur le
les sanctions et sur la livraison
d'armes en Ukraine je crois pas on s'en
fout un peu les livraisons d'armes c'est
plus problématique quand même
bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a à dire sur
la guerre en Ukraine
la vie humaine ou ailleurs
peut-être que la situation tu as moi je
suis pour une analyse de situation
historique ce qui se passe au Yémen
n'est pas ce qui se passe en Ukraine non
non
ce qui se passe au Yémen puisque
tu as parlé tout à l'heure de l'Italie
de l'ingérence de Van derlayen dans les
affaires italiennes
en Yémen tu si on est pour
l'autodétermination des peuples tu as
une ingérence de l'Arabie Saoudite dans
les affaires du Yémen
d'accord et donc il n'y a pas de raison
de livrer des armes à l'Arabie Saoudite
pour qu'elle s'ingère dans les affaires
du Yémen c'est des armes pour se
défendre non puisque c'est pour
intervenir ils interviennent on sait
vraisemblablement c'est assez documenté
que il y a des armes françaises qui sont
utilisés par l'Arabie Saoudite au Yémen
la ministre de la Défense elle m'avait
dit que c'était pour se défendre mais
alors la même manière que nous on peut
aller très bien les États-Unis peuvent
aller se défendre à des milliers de
kilomètres de chez eux l'Arabie Saoudite
sans doute se défend sur le territoire
des autres c'est quand même une
conception assez particulière de ce
qu'on appelle la défense mais bon
la situation quand même en Ukraine n'est
pas la même puisque non
ce qui se passe en Ukraine en
l'occurrence tu as une décision de
d'intervention d'ingérence d'agression
de la Russie sur un territoire reconnu
qui est le territoire ukrainien donc ça
lui a pris comme ça un matin non
non il a dit bon allez on va on va
massacrer 4 5 6 7 8 familles du crédit
aujourd'hui
comme ça d'un coup on sait que il peut y
avoir sur ce qui s'est passé depuis des
années des années en
Ukraine
un non respect des accords par les deux
parties et un jeu du chat et de la
souris tu vois et donc il y a on peut
dire qu'il y a une responsabilité
partagée dans ce qui s'est passé sur le
terrain
il y avait bien quelqu'un qui partageait
la responsabilité avec l'Ukraine
c'est c'est très clair que il y a eu des
l'OTAN tu sais l'Ukraine
n'est pas dans l'OTAN mais l'OTAN était
déjà en Ukraine donc voilà maintenant il
n'en reste pas moins que le propos donc
que toi non je voilà
j'assume ces propos là l'OTAN était déjà
en Ukraine maintenant la réalité quand
même enfin c'est pas quand même c'est
une agression de la Russie sur le crâne
donc que dans chaque cadre là il y a une
solidarité pour
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine moi ça me choque
pas au contraire tu vas me faire la
vas-y donc la solidarité face à
l'Ukraine est tout à fait compréhensible
on se lève pas un matin en envoyant ses
troupes pour aller massacrer le pays qui
est des nazis pas de nazis qui est des
éléments radicaux dans l'armée ou pas on
est d'accord quand la Russie a dit il y
a des mecs qui se font bombarder des
ruissophones ils se font bombarder X il
envoie les hélicoptères il veut aller
bombarder c'est normal
c'était le pays qui combattait des
séparatistes que les choses soient bien
clair ce que je comprends pas bien là
les séparatistes c'est bien ou c'est pas
bien non si on a normalement une
reconnaissance internationale des
frontières de l'Ukraine à partir du
moment où tu violes les frontières de
l'autre c'est toi qui en tort et là je
dirais que on peut dire que c'est une
faute morale mais par ailleurs c'était
une erreur stratégique de la Russie une
erreur stratégique pourquoi parce que
manifestement
elle elle a surestimé sa puissance
elle a sous-estimé non seulement l'armée
ukrainienne mais les soutiens qu'elle
pouvait avoir
est-ce qu'elle a sous-estimé aussi c'est
l'unité du bloc occidental elle pensait
que ça se fondrait entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis et ça c'est pas fondu
avec du coup une série d'échecs tu vois
tu peux
par terre
avec une série d'échecs
il échoue le Poutine échoue à rapproché
l'Ukraine et la Russie au contraire
c'est l'inverse qui se produit c'est à
dire que
il n'y a pas de solidarité du peuple
ukrainien quand les Russes ils arrivent
en Russie c'est en Ukraine pardon c'est
tout l'inverse il se produit il
apparemment il comptait un peu là-dessus
mais y compris les russophone ils ont
pas été enthousiasmés par l'arrivée de
l'armée de l'armée russe tu as une
séparation de qui se produit pas entre
l'Europe et les États-Unis il y avait ce
pari là et au contraire
nous ça nous jette quasiment dans les
bras de l'OTAN c'est la conséquence de
ça
qui voulaient la France
traditionnellement à l'utiliser quelque
part la Russie et pas seulement la
Russie comme un espèce de contrepoids
pour pas être pleinement lié aux
Américains et quand même il y a eu des
moments où on a réussi à se détacher de
des Américains on va pas faire la guerre
en direct
je pense le dire que nous a valu ça en
tout cas ça nous a valu à mon avis c'est
le dernier moment où la France est
grande dans l'ordre international parce
que même quand tu es un petit pays je
considère pas que la France le soit mais
le nom
s'en rappelle encore le nom il raisonne
dans le monde et le nom il raisonne dans
l'histoire y compris quand c'est des
petits ou des moyens mais qui se mettent
à dire non au grand et je pense que
c'est le dernier moment où finalement il
y a eu en dehors des Coupes du Monde un
sentiment de fierté nationale dans
l'ordre mondial et on a fait raisonner
notre nom n.om tu vois et donc bah voilà
là ce qui se produit fait que le la
troisième voie la voix d'indépendance et
tout ça elle va être beaucoup plus
compliquée à défendre
médiation une force d'interposition et
ainsi de suite même se dire que bah il
faut être ni dans l'un ni dans l'autre
et puis il faut être tu vois dans un
espèce de ce que ce qu'avait sortir de
l'OTAN ou pas là aujourd'hui si tu veux
je pense que c'est une position qui
n'est pas défendable
aujourd'hui moi je pense que c'est une
position qui n'est pas audible et
ce qu'il faut sortir ou pas non mais je
te redis c'est une position qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas défendable et qui
n'est pas audible d'autres temps
viendront
mais il dit course mais là aujourd'hui
au moment venu aujourd'hui
ou il y a une
agression je pense que avant la question
se posait et c'est là où c'est pour moi
une faute stratégique que produit
Poutine parce que y compris les pays qui
décidaient de pas se brouiller avec lui
de à la fois par des intérêts
énergétiques mais aussi parce que il y
avait quelque part un contrepoids et ça
ça faisait qu'on n'était pas vassalisé
complètement et encore par une puissance
M1 là il va y avoir un adossement qui va
être renforcé à ça donc voilà ce que
produit pour moi
l'intervention de la Russie en Ukraine
qu'est-ce que la France doit faire avec
ça elle doit débarquer en disant
maintenant ça suffit on fait une force
d'interposition
on est plus crédible parce qu'on fait
partie de l'OTAN qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire comment on calme les choses avec
la Russie et comment on fait pour aider
l'Ukraine pour éviter qu'ils s'en
prennent deux fois plus bon d'abord il y
a ce qui est fait je veux dire il est
évident que l'Ukraine
à quoi on s'attendait peut-être que toi
tu avais lu dans la boule de cristal et
tu t'attendais pas
on va sur le terrain on écoute les gens
c'est très sympa il y a aussi c'est très
sympa aussi mais on peut aller à la
semaine des ambassadeurs voir ce qui se
passe au Quai d'Orsay on peut écouter ce
qui se passe au Quai d'Orsay on peut
écouter les diplomates d'autres pays et
on peut voir comment les gens
s'organisent et celui qui aurait dû
faire son travail aurait pu voir que la
guerre venait à grands pas
alors tu sais quand il y a des
bombardiers russes qui passent devant
Brest et que nous en face de nous on a
l'ambassade ou le ministre conseiller de
l'ambassade de Russie et on lui dit
alors arthem les deux bombardiers que tu
as fait passer devant notre base de
sous-marin ils étaient chargés ou ils
étaient pas chargé et pourquoi il y
avait pas les transpondeurs
ça ce genre de question technique si tu
avais posé ou tu avais croisé le truc tu
voyais que la guerre commence à chauffer
un peu quand tu vois les pays nordiques
dira leur population bien avant la
guerre bon alors écoutez avant la crise
énergétique la crise du covid ils font
passer leur population bon vous savez
c'est en train de chauffer quand même un
peu avec les Russes on avait d'ailleurs
contacté l'ambassade de Suède ce serait
bien d'avoir deux semaines de stock chez
vous juste au cas où
ce genre de petit fascicule cette vraie
allumer des lumières ça c'est des trucs
qu'ils ont pas vu venir ok d'Orsay
apparemment pas apparemment pas un peu
comme le covid
en effet si tu savais que la crise du
covid elle est arrivée 6 mois à l'avance
et on a eu que 17 jours avant
c'est-à-dire que le 17 janvier on avait
des gars sur place qui nous au courant
mieux que la DGSE n'est au courant le
[__] de Quai d'Orsay d'accord désolé
mais
le ce à quoi moi je m'attendais j'étais
pas le seul mais peut-être pas toi
est-ce que tu t'attendais à une
résistance de l'armée ukrainienne bien
entendu je m'attendais pas du tout à ça
moi je m'attendais
à un effondrement militaire de l'Ukraine
et que Kiev serait pris beaucoup plus
rapidement que ça
fait depuis 2014 qui sont formés aux
techniques de guérilla tu devrais écrire
tes papiers à l'avance comme ça
ils nous disaient tout le temps il faut
faire des trucs faut laisser des traces
nous on a laissé les traces on est des
interviews
une autre annonce tout ça alors sur le
coup des bombardiers va voir les
interviews qu'on a fait avec l'ambassade
de Russie où on leur pose clairement les
questions de qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
forces là le mec qui nous dit mais vous
êtes en train de nous parler d'une
nouvelle guerre froide et bien où est-ce
que tu annonces que il y aura une
résistance de l'armée ukrainienne
si jamais tu nous dis tu as annoncé
toutes tes prophéties à l'avance
ça s'appelle de la prospective
parce que dire des prophéties c'est
réducteur et péjoratif
et si les politiques commencent à parler
comme ça on peut muscler le débat tu
veux qu'on muscles
tu vois et que on en avait bah voilà ça
serait quand même nulle part ça tombe
bien parce qu'on va faire venir un mec
qui n'a jamais parlé à la télé et qui en
bien en poste et ce mec-là il nous suit
depuis 20 ans
d'accord et on va le moucher et il va
être obligé de se faire moucher en
direct parce qu'on lui a mis des pilules
tu comprends
pas d'accord donc en revanche quand même
parce que tu vas gérer le bateau qui
coule pourquoi parce que quand tu as pu
d'énergie tu as un bateau qui coule non
mais là ce que tu me dis avec le mec que
tu vas recevoir ou je sais pas ça me
concerne pas vous l'aurez vos histoires
tous les deux tu vois mais moi j'ai pas
de je sais pas la prospective en la
matière il est clair que je l'ai pas et
que ce que on pressentait ça serait un
effondrement militaire de l'Ukraine et
ce qui est le pari qui était fait
c'était un effondrement économique de la
Russie et au fond ce qu'on voit c'était
le Bruno Le Maire qui disait voilà avec
les sanctions économiques qu'on va
prendre six mois il y aura une chute de
la Russie est-ce que s'il prend très
cher avec les sanctions très très très
économique il s'en sortent quand même
moi 6% de PIB c'est pas dégringola de la
plus totale d'accord mais qu'en revanche
sur le plan militaire c'est pas la
victoire qui était attendue par Poutine
en tout cas toi tu avais peut-être cette
prospective là mais Poutine il
établissait une autre prospective quant
à la conquête du territoire ukrainien tu
vois et qui n'a pas sorti ses gros
avions il a pas sorti ses gros missile
quoi ça se passe pas exactement comme
comme il espérait je pense tu vois et
donc on se retrouve quasiment dans un
scénario inversé ou sur le plan
économique ça tient et sur le plan
militaire en revanche elle ne
contresensive qui se met en place bon et
donc c'est c'est le résultat aujourd'hui
de la guerre en Ukraine ça veut dire là
à partir de ce moment-là c'est d'une
part que les intérêts de l'Europe ne
soient pas complètement confondu avec
les intérêts Ukrainiens c'est-à-dire que
jusqu'où on mène la guerre est-ce qu'on
mène la guerre jusqu'à la libération
totale du pays
c'est bien parti pour selon Ursula on va
voir mais ou bien est-ce que si jamais
il y a un enlisement
il y a la nécessité d'un compromis qui
est passé à un moment et la deuxième
chose c'est que on confondent pas nos
intérêts avec les intérêts américains
parce que il est évident que ça ne gêne
pas oui les intérêts américains qu'il y
a une guerre qui se déroule sur le sol
européen qui affaiblissent
continuellement la Russie mais qui nous
aussi nous affaiblissent tu vois et donc
il y a un moment il y a trouvé le chemin
de nos intérêts à nous sans il s'agit
pas de laisser tomber l'Ukraine mais de
nos intérêts à nous qui viennent
proposer un compromis et
enfin là on va voir ce qui se passe dans
les semaines ou les mois à venir sur le
terrain militaire quand même puisque il
y a encore des on n'est pas dans un
enlisement de la guerre il va falloir
que j'ai de la flotte moi
les gars
revenons à nos moutons
tu te rends compte que là parce que on
te dit qu'il va y avoir relocalisation
et compagnie on vient de signer qui le
patronat les ministres tu vois les
dirigeants du pays te disent
relocalisation de l'économie on signe un
accord de d'échange avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande pour l'importation de
mouton de viande havine de lait aux vins
de fromage au vin comme si on avait
besoin de
que d'avoir des des moutons qui font des
dizaines de milliers de kilomètres à
travers la planète
et ça ça continue on est dans une folie
qui continue alors qu'on voit très bien
que ça nous entraîne droit dans le mur
revenons à nos moutons Bruno Le Maire
est-ce que c'est un bon ministre des
Finances
ça dépend pour qui
ça dépend beaucoup quand on dit qu'en 50
mandat de Macron les 5 premières
fortunes françaises elles ont vu leur
patrimoine triplés je pense que pour eux
c'est un excellent ministre des Finances
et comme ce sont les mécènes et les
premiers mandataires de Macron Bruno Le
Maire et compagnie d'un certain point lu
c'est un très bon ministre de finances
quand il dit que ça va être à l'euro
près mais que à l'euro près ça va être
toutes les dépenses qui concernent
Bernadette Géraldine et Hayat et que en
revanche on va quand même trouver 8
milliards d'euros pour baisser les
impôts CVAE c'est
un ministre qui opère des choix de
classe tu sais la difficulté qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il y a des choix
politiques fiscaux très profond qui sont
effectués mais qu'au fond ils sont
naturalisés
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'ils
sont pas présentés comme étant de la
politique qui sont pas présentés comme
étant de véritables choix mais qui sont
recouverts d'abord du covid une maladie
une fatalité un fait naturel et
maintenant de la guerre en Ukraine avec
est-ce qu'on peut
et donc à partir du moment là des choix
politiques profonds s'opèrent sous cette
habillage là sous ce costume là et se
retrouve naturalisé en un mode on n'a
pas le choix tu vois c'est il n'y a pas
d'alternative de Margaret Thatcher et au
fond ils nous enferment en permanence
dans un c'est comme ça dans un on n'a
pas le choix qui aujourd'hui se fait
sous ce costume de la guerre en Ukraine
quoi alors qu'il y a des tas de choix il
y a des tas de choix y compris sur
l'énergie est-ce qu'on revient à un
tarif réglementé pour tout le monde
c'est à dire
pas seulement pour les particuliers mais
aussi pour les collectivités mais aussi
pour les entreprises c'est un choix et
aujourd'hui donc de couper le marché
si tu es un peu si on coupe le marché
qu'est-ce qui va nous filer de
l'électricité cet hiver alors que notre
parc il est bancaire
on a encore on a un parc en tout cas
tout un parc qui surtout ce qui est la
production intérieure d'électricité tu
peux décider là de couper le marché
d'accord donc si je coupe le marché au
jour d'aujourd'hui EDF arrive avec sa
petite cape bleue et dit c'est bon je
fournis à tout le monde non peut-être
pas tout le monde en face on a déjà une
large production d'électricité en France
et ben tout ça tu peux le sortir du
marché le remettre sur tarif réglementé
c'est un choix et un choix politique tu
vois et ça c'est possible et là ça n'a
pas de coût mais si ça n'a pas de coup
ça n'a pas de coup ça c'est un choix
d'un mécanisme de marché que tu choisis
donc là au contraire tu sais très bien
qu'on a lié les tarifs non seulement on
a déréglementé les tarifs de
l'électricité mais en plus on les a lié
au prix du gaz
non mais attends il faut être doublement
malade donc ça c'est un choix Bruno Le
Maire est-ce que le bouclier tarifaire
c'est une bonne mauvaise idée c'est une
rustine c'est un pansement sur une jambe
de bois
non mais c'est une rustine sur ce que je
viens de te dire je si jamais il y avait
pas ça ça serait pour les gens la
catastrophe intégrale et immédiate pour
les gens oui pour les gens qui
rends-toi compte je disais parler de
rationnement tout à l'heure mais
rends-toi compte pour en gros ça dépend
on va dire un quart de la population
le retour de d'un rationnement qui est
déjà là donc si tu veux soit tu opères
du plancher plafond qui est une forme de
rationnement organisée et qui essaye de
se faire dans une forme de justice soit
tu laisses faire le marché et il opère
un rationnement seulement sur les uns et
de manière et y compris sur les besoins
fondamentaux quant à on te dit que 25%
c'est pas un truc que je sors de mon
chapeau c'est 25% des Français se
restait traînent sur les quantités dans
leur assiette tu vois et au fond au
niveau des repas oui mais ça mais moi si
je veux ce à quoi j'assiste c'est un
retour de la fin tu vois dans mon film
merci patron il y a un moment où il y a
le couple d'ouvriers les clures qui
vient dire mais nous on mange pas tous
les trois pas par jour on et puis à Noël
c'est un peu de fromage sur une tartine
tu vois et à ce moment-là dans la salle
quand j'étais en salle de cinéma tu
avais un blanc qui se faisait les gens
se disaient mais c'est pas possible on
est en France c'est pas possible et
maintenant c'est toutes les semaines moi
que j'ai des gens et des gens qui
travaillent tu vois j'avais un
conducteur de car scolaire qui est à 800
euros par mois parce que ça c'est trois
heures le matin deux heures le soir et
qui m'explique comment il saute des
repas
et comment il va piquer des trucs au
supermarché donc et toutes les semaines
elles veulent sur les modes de beurre et
les steaks pas encore mais tu vois et tu
as
le temps de covid où on a accepté que
notre jeunesse
et c'est pas fini mais
moindre que pendant la perle du covid
mais soit touché par la
sous-alimentation
des queues d'étudiantes d'étudiants qui
faisaient la queue pour avoir des
écoliers
pour le CROUS mais ils ont fait un truc
qui était même pas organisé la charité
mais ils ont lancé un plan un plan en
disant voilà vous voulez faire des dons
aux étudiants voici le numéro où il faut
donner c'est à dire c'est même pas
l'organisation de la charité eux-mêmes
substituez vous à l'état et c'est ça le
rôle donc simplement pour te dire que on
a un retour pour moi de la fin sur un
quart de la population et tu as un
retour du froid là
tu vois donc deux mots dont tu pensais
être débarrassé après il y a la maladie
voilà mais quand tu vois les
restrictions sur les dépenses de soins
45% des Français qui sont en découvert
tous les mois tu montres les dents
symboles extrêmement intéressant les
dents parce que voilà quand François
Hollande a dit les 100 dents moi je me
suis pas braqué contre Hollande là
dessus parce que au fond c'est la
réalité que tu peux reconnaître
l'appartenance de classe des gens à leur
dentition simplement quand tu es de
gauche qu'est-ce que tu fais tu
n'établis pas là-dessus un cynique je te
demande comment tu peux transformer ça
tu te demandes comment tu vas avoir des
dentistes qui vont aller dans des
camionnettes amener des soins pour les
gens au pied de leur HLM ou dans les
campagnes et tu cherches à mettre en
oeuvre quelque chose qui lutte contre ça
et donc voilà là tu vois on est dans ce
temps de rationnement pour les uns et de
gavage pour les autres et si tu laisses
faire le marché c'était notre discussion
de départ mais si tu laisses faire le
marché le marché ne fera que accroître
ça quand je t'écoute parler
avec tout le respect que je te dois
beaucoup de respect tu es député de la
République quand même
j'ai l'impression que tu fais que du
symptôme éthique comme une infirmière
qui court dans une unité de soie
palliatifs volant c'est à dire que tu es
là à essayer de
d'apporter un soulagement au plus faible
ou plus précaire ou sans voix bon moi
j'aimerais que tu me donnes
ta moelle épinière la moelle épinière
ton prisme de lecture
qu'est-ce que tu vois pour les 5 ans à
venir pour la France d'abord je suis pas
d'accord avec ton constat je fais pas
que du symptôme
puisque je te dis que au fond tout ça il
y a une colonne vertébrale que je viens
te répéter si jamais c'est pas c'est
clair c'est la volonté ou le marché
c'est l'organisation de la société où le
laisser faire par le porte-monnaie tu
vois et il y a un choix qui est opéré et
qui produit tous les saints tomes que je
te décris c'est sédition ou soumission
c'est même pas la sédition c'est
organisation ou soumission au marché tu
vois et
c'est un choix qui est qui n'est pas
nouveau dans notre histoire que de se
dire que on laisse faire les dominants
et qui vont s'auto-organiser dans une
forme de couteaucratie ou alors il y a
la forme démocratique qui décide
ensemble de quels sont les besoins
fondamentaux et comment on organise la
société pour la transformer ouais vers
où on canalise l'énergie vers nous on
canalise les capitaux vers où on
canalise la main d'oeuvre
il faut qu'on chope le pouvoir quand
même tu vois alors je ne veux pas faire
confiance qu'au pouvoir ce que je veux
dire c'est que moi je suis pour un
dépassement de dialectique des
contradictions sur plein de points
mais entre autres sur le haut et le bas
il faut pas qu'on croit que si jamais on
prend le pouvoir et que ça se fait avec
en bas un vide d'initiative privé on en
fera quelque chose
il doit y avoir le lien entre les deux
tu vois
l'un des grands temps de notre histoire
on va y être à nouveau sur les retraites
la retraite tu vois l'organiser la
volonté ou le laisser faire
que fait des millénaires de laisser
faire c'est la misère dans les classes
populaires quand elles vieillissent
quand elles ont la chance de vieillir
c'était ça pendant des siècles et des
siècles quand le on vieillissait dans
les classes populaires on se retrouvait
à la charité ou bien
c'était les enfants qui prenaient en
charge les vieux tu vois et ça a été ça
peut qui survivaient aussi hein et donc
c'était et c'était à partir comme
appartement naturel des choses
1945 une décision est prise de créer le
minimum vieillesse et les retraites quel
est l'effet politique de ça de la
volonté politique en 30 ans parce qu'il
faut une génération pour installer ce
genre de mesure tu as une division par 4
du taux de pauvreté chez les personnes
âgées pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité de notre pays
tu as le taux de pauvreté des personnes
âgées qui passent sous le taux de
pauvreté la moyenne nationale une
fatalité est vaincue par un choix
politique donc mais je veux dire que ce
choix que fait Ambroise Croizat ministre
des travailleurs en 1945 il n'aurait pas
pu le faire si jamais il y avait pas eu
déjà des expériences d'en bas s'il n'y
avait pas eu des initiatives qui avaient
été prises et c'est les caisses de
solidarité dans les usines ça a été des
fédérations qui ont mis en place des
mutuelles et qui a fait que ça ouvert
l'imaginaire à lui qui s'est dit
finalement généraliser ça et faire ce
vaste plan de sécurité sociale c'est
faisable mais qui a ouvert aussi
l'imaginaire dans le pays et où les gens
se sont dit mais ce qui nous propose le
gars c'est pas délirant puisque ça
existe déjà il y a des il y a du déjà là
et ce qui est important c'est pour ça
que je te dis il faut à la fois le
pouvoir mais s'il y a le pouvoir sentier
du déjà là sans qu'elle lui déjà là sur
le terrain de l'agriculture sans qu'il y
a du déjà là sur le terrain du bâtiment
c'est qui ont dû déjà là par
l'initiative privé des associations des
entrepreneurs de tu vois à la base le
pouvoir en haut ne suffira pas il nous
faut une jonction entre les deux donc il
n'y a pas de raison de pas faire du déjà
là maintenant y compris de manière
ténue tu vois quelque part tu es un déjà
là sur le plan médiatique puisque si on
dit qu'on veut transformer la société ça
passe aussi par une transformation de ce
qu'on met dans la tête des gens donc des
médias oui et donc c'est comment on fait
du déjà là et que quand il y a le
pouvoir il y a assez d'imagination qui
grouille dans la société pour qu'on
puisse mettre en oeuvre des mesures qui
sont sinon paraissent paraît très
complètement délirante question internet
que je vais synthétiser parce qu'il y en
a eu plusieurs le parc thermonucléaire
français tu en penses quoi il faut le
continuer il faut recharger le nucléaire
faut se décharger nucléaires on fait
quoi déjà je vais te dire une chose
c'est que la sûreté du nucléaire c'est
pas pour demain c'est pour aujourd'hui
que notamment moi je fais l'utiliser du
reportage c'est mon côté je suis
reporter quand même c'est mon métier moi
que le terrain
et l'autre il faut à la fois le terrain
et des éclairages intellectuels qui
viennent de l'eau tu vois il faut le
dépassement dialectique de cette
contradiction là aussi si tu regardes
que le terrain le terrain le terrain en
fait tu t'en sors pas si tu es que dans
la grande pensée en haut tu t'en sors
pas et je pense qu'il faut une espèce de
entre les deux et donc le passage par la
sous-traitance dont je parlais tout à
l'heure en matière de bâtiment tu vois
mais le passage par la sous-traitance le
fait de l'avoir vu tu vois autant je
suis pas allé en Russie en Ukraine
autant
le magnifique Moscou c'est magnifique
mais et bien le
ça produit une insécurité pour les
travailleurs des travailleurs du
nucléaire qui sont dans des sociétés
d'intérim qui passent qui retournent
tout ça aujourd'hui plus des trois
quarts des intervenants dans les
centrales nucléaires c'est de l'ordre de
la sous-traitance et non pas de l'ordre
d'EDF et ça produit une une insécurité
pour le système également parce que les
informations elles circulent beaucoup
moins bien avec les sous-traitants que
quand il y a un opérateur public et
unifié donc ils forment des soudeurs et
qui forment des soudeurs donc tu là on y
compris dans tu devrais être le cœur du
réacteur tu vois l'énergie est une
énergie qui est quand même dangereuse le
nucléaire et bien même quand c'est
dangereux aussi
les conséquences alors il y a eu des il
y a des barrages qui ont pété et ça a
produit des choses dans des vallées les
conséquences quand même des explosions
nucléaires sont d'une nature
encore plus impressionnante quand même
mais donc pas seulement impressionnante
mais
y compris sur ce terrain là on a été
capable de mettre en oeuvre cette folie
du coup du coup du coup du coup ne
regardez le travail et les
investissements que comme étant un coup
tu sais c'est Keynes qui disait que
c'est on rentrait dans le cauchemar du
comptable
ou en ayant une vue à très court terme
lui disait on préfère construire des
taudis dont on sait qui vont pas tenir
30 ans plutôt que de se demander comment
qu'elle construit quelque chose de beau
de confortable de lumineux et qui
tiendra dans la durée et c'est qui
est-ce qui disait si si jamais on le
pouvait on éteindrait les étoiles et le
soleil parce qu'il verse pas de
dividendes tu vois c'est beau non mais
donc voilà et y compris sur le terrain
du nucléaire on a raisonné avec ce cette
cerveau réduit à une calculette bon on a
résonné on va dire les partis politiques
et et les fonctionnaires on cherche de
gérer ça les dirigeants donc le
nucléaire on fait 4 5 6 directement en
plus là on fait quoi moi je te dis sur
la question que tu poses sur l'énergie
aujourd'hui
ce que je pense c'est qu'il faut un
vaste débat avec les Français tu vois
mais vraiment pour planifier ouais il
faut un vaste débat avec les Français
sur quelle sobriété on est la
trajectoire énergétique qu'on valide
pour le pays
en termes de
l'incon valide mais c'est pas qu'on
valide là c'est qu'on peut se permettre
est-ce que quand tu es dans ton avion et
que tu planes ça va mais quand tes
vitesses elles ralentit tu planes plus
donc là c'est quel trajectoire on peut
se permettre en terme de décroissance
si tu dis que tu veux construire 50
centrales nucléaires c'est une option
donc ouais voilà mais donc c'est comme
c'est pas comme si on avait mais quand
je dis de toute façon tu sais moi que il
faille moins consommer d'énergie c'est
pas comme si tu ne me le faisais dire
d'aujourd'hui tu vois mais non mais
attends ça fait 23 ans que ça fait 23
ans que je le dis si tu veux de la
quasiment dès la naissance de Fakir je
dis que on peut pas se permettre ça tu
vois bon donc c'est pas comme si c'était
un truc étant ennuyé par un visa partner
ou pas
pourquoi ennuyer ah non mais bizarrement
donc l'histoire vise appartenance et je
veux dire quand même c'est quand même
dingue enfin le l'obsession de Bernard
puisque donc il a fait paraître il a
payé des non journalistes mais déguisés
en journaliste j'ai pas suivi cette
histoire c'est Bernard Arnault qui
finançait je comprends pas
il y a eu des articles qui sont parus
sur des sites obscurs pour me dénigrer
tu vois des tribunes signées fiches
Wikipédia aussi est passé non je sais
pas j'ai pas regardé mais enfin en tout
cas et signé par des bons et en fait la
personne qui devait faire ce travail-là
comme c'était moi et comme elle avait de
l'estime pour moi et c'est pas possible
je vais pas faire ça et c'est là qu'elle
s'est mis à raconter comment on lui
faisait faire des faux articles des
fausses tribunes signées par des fausses
personnes avec des pseudos de gens qui
n'existaient pas et donc en fait c'est
c'est terminé on va recevoir quelqu'un
qui parlera de ça plus en détail un peu
plus loin et donc ces deux-là qui est
parti le truc où
le rôle d'avisa Partners en l'occurrence
c'était financé par LVMH dans le cas me
concernant mais ça a pu être financé par
des gouvernements étrangers pour publier
les tribunes et compagnies et c'était
une enquête qui a été reprise et
approfondie par d'autres médias mais
bizarrement tous les autres médias sont
poursuivis chacun ne l'est pas
pour l'instant pour l'instant
revenons à nos sujets énergétiques
Bruno Le Maire est-ce que on peut lui
faire confiance et Bruno Le Maire et le
reste du gouvernement sur la sécurité
alimentaire des Français est-ce que la
sécurité alimentaire des Français est
assurée je parle pas des modes de peur
congelés en Europe est-ce que
on est sécurisé pour l'alimentation en
France
en tout cas on n'a pas changé tu vas
quand je te disais tout à l'heure
Emmanuel Macron déléguer notre
alimentation notre protection à d'autres
est une folie on n'a rien changé et on
est toujours dans la même dépendance on
n'a pas réduit notre dépendance au
contraire je te dis avec tous les
accords de libre-échange qui sont en
cours on accroît de notre dépendance et
on ne construit pas notre autonomie
aujourd'hui ça c'est une certitude donc
et
pour construire notre autonomie je vais
au moins tu auras compris ma colonne
vertébrale et tu vas pas dire que je ne
traite que l'essence symptômes même si
je te parle de Bernadette et de Cindy un
petit peu mais il me semble pas que je
sois venu faire de la pleurniche mais
faut construire notre autonomie ça
suppose encore une fois qu'on fasse le
choix d'organiser la société par de la
volonté politique ou qu'on fasse le
choix d'un marché mondialisé dans lequel
se trouve à la fois le blé et qui est
traité comme un produit financier tu le
sais c'est très tu es traité comme un
produit financier et ça c'est un choix
c'est un choix politique profond de
décider que le blé y compris que le blé
qui est produit ici va subir des
fluctuations de marché ou alors qu'on va
au moins réguler le marché intérieur tu
vois et donc pour apporter à la fois de
la sécurité alimentaire mais aussi de la
sécurité de revenus au producteurs et
aujourd'hui le choix est fait de laisser
le blé et le reste comme un produit
spéculatif
l'eau aussi ça va bientôt être un
produit spéculatif
tu sais je vais je vais être je vais
radoter mais ce que je te dis sur ça
vous aussi sur l'eau si et c'est pas si
on a une nécessité de consommer moins
d'eau est-ce que tu laisses faire la
main invisible du marché et ceux qui ont
des piscines privées mais pas seulement
ceux qui ont des terrains de golf à
arroser ils auront tout à fait la
possibilité
de payer pour ça et ça sera sans doute
pour eux indolore sinon peut-être un
petit relevé le relèvement de leur
cotisations au club tu vois il faisait
tromper il y a aussi des gens pauvres
qui font du golf il y a des petits golfs
qui essaient de survivre avec des petits
moyens très bien d'accord ok enfin tu
vois l'idée de toute façon quand même
bon et soit tu dis que ça doit aller
vers un certain nombre de besoins Ess au
final et que à ce moment là il faut
organiser la société et c'est pas
seulement le prix de l'eau qui doit
l'organiser et ça doit pas s'organiser
dans l'urgence non plus parce que tu
vois Macron il nous prend dans l'urgence
permanence face au covid ça a été ça n'a
été qu'une succession d'urgence on
apprenait le soir à 20h comment on
allait devoir vivre le lendemain à 8h du
matin tu vois non mais la prévision
normalement tu dois tu dois te demander
comment tu fais pour adapter la société
à moins d'eau ça veut dire que sur le
terrain agricole il y a sans doute un
certain nombre de production type maïs
ainsi de suite qu'il faut diminuer
comment on va faire de l'éthanol avec
notre colza comment on va faire comment
on va nourrir nos poulets
ça veut dire aussi puisque l'éthanol de
toute façon je l'élimine est-ce que je
suis pour la production d'éthanol non
non
les terres elles doivent servir à se
nourrir
les voitures elles doivent servir à se
nourrir et pas à se déplacer c'est clair
pour moi ça ça doit être une règle qui
doit être posée ça doit être papa être
pour du biocarbure et tout ça les terres
doivent servir à nous nourrir bon et
ensuite tu dis les poulets
quelle viande qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme
viande peut se permettre
mais qu'est-ce que on veut comme viande
tu vois moi je suis partisan du moins de
viande mieux de viande c'est à dire
qu'elle a la place le bouffer de la
viande tout le temps on la faisant venir
de l'autre bout de la planète ou
d'élevage hyper concentré et bien tu te
dire que sans doute on mangera moins de
viande
mais que cette viande elle aura elle
aura été en pâture enfin tu vois un peu
le truc quoi donc voilà mais ça c'est
pas le marché qui le décide c'est des
règles que tu poses tu sais moi je suis
pas député par hasard
non non je suis pas seulement parce que
j'aime me les campagnes j'adore ça
d'accord mais c'est pas seulement ça
c'est parce que au fond je veux dire je
suis pas devenu mère je suis pas devenu
conseiller départemental pourquoi parce
que tu as un cœur non parce que tu as
des yeux je pense qu'on peut être mère
ou conseiller départemental avec un cœur
et des yeux mais en revanche les
oreilles je crois à la règle qu'on se
fixe et qu'on respecte
voilà et donc au fond si tu dis que
c'est le marché que c'est le laisser
faire tu ne crois pas à la règle commune
qu'on se fixe et qu'on respecte question
est-ce que tu sais ce que c'est un choc
Volker
c'est un choc sur le la hausse des taux
d'intérêt non la hausse du taux de
chômage
comment on fait pour convaincre
l'inflation
ceci quelle est à quoi est dû
l'inflation tu vois parce que
l'inflation
à la sur demande à la surconsommation
des inflations qui peuvent avoir des
causes différentes l'inflation des
années 70 sur les salaires par exemple
et pas du tout la même que celle
d'aujourd'hui qui est pas une inflation
sur les salaires puisque tu es une
inflation de 6% et des salaires qui
augmentent de 3%. donc tu es à -3% les
gens qui travaillent cette année déjà le
serrage de ceinture c'est trois crans
d'accord et donc voilà ce que fait le
marché tu vois et en revanche tu as une
inflation juridique tout à l'heure quand
je t'ai parlé de de des portes
containers et de l'énergie qui faisait
que à la place de représenter 3% du PIB
et représenté désormais le double 6% du
PIB ce qui est un basculement formidable
et tu as une inflation financière
les dividendes tout ça c'est une
inflation spéculative du capital qui est
absolument considérable tu vois donc ça
alors comment tu fais face à l'inflation
bah tu as une responsabilité des banques
centrales ou pas
la production de oui oui moi j'ai
compris je comprends rien à la monnaie
je vais te dire ce que je pense je sais
peut-être quelque chose qui fait que on
raisonne pas la même manière c'est que
j'ai une très faible capacité
d'abstraction je le pense mais tu vois
je pense avec mes pieds
je pense vraiment tu vois tu es
impératif je pense alors avec les
situations concrètes que je rencontre et
qui me font cheminer dans le ma tête et
qui me font élever une pensée à partir
des cas concrets que je rencontre et
c'est de là que je tire des
raisonnements des lois plus générales et
ainsi de suite et on peut concevoir le
mouvement inverse des mouvements qui
sont plus de l'ordre de gens qui sont
d'ordre philosophe qui sont dans les
abstractions et c'est pas une critique
que je fais à ça et qui ensuite regarde
la société et pense la réalité sociale
en fonction des idées qu'ils avaient
auparavant tu comprends ce que je veux
dire mais moi je suis vraiment un un
penseur en marchant pourquoi je dis ça
c'était quoi ton le point de départ en
marchant
avec les pieds mais l'inflation
qu'est-ce que je qu'est-ce que c'était
le conflit
au fond la monnaie tu vois je comprenais
pas ce que c'était que la monnaie c'est
con c'est un truc qu'on a tous les jours
et je comprenais pas ce que c'était la
monnaie et un jour avec mes pieds je
suis allé faire un reportage à la Banque
centrale européenne à Francfort je sais
pas si il est déjà allé bon tu vois
comme je veux pas en Ukraine en Russie
mais je vais à la banque c'est trop
dangereux là-bas pour nous
je vais à la Banque centrale européenne
et j'ai le droit à ma visite guidée
alors
si tu veux je te raconterai mais j'ai le
droit mais tu étais député à l'époque
non reporter France Inter l'émission
Là-bas si j'y suis j'ai le droit ma
visite guidée et je sais plus ça faisait
au quatrième étage n'hésitez pas au
septième étage parce que j'ai eu le
droit à une rencontre avec Jean-Claude
Trichet le président à l'époque de la
Banque centrale européenne pour terminer
et je peux te dire que jamais j'ai eu en
le sentiment en quittant une pièce que
la température était aussi froide
contenu de la nature de notre échange un
peu conflictuel tu vois mais c'était
très chaleureux au départ il était
content de me recevoir et à la fin avec
mes questions sur l'obsession
l'inflation parce que tu vois c'est la
Banque centrale européenne a pour
obsession de ne pas avoir d'inflation
parce que l'inflation c'est quand même
traditionnellement quelque chose qui
vient gruger le capital et qui
potentiellement si jamais il y a une
indexation des salaires sur l'inflation
ce que je souhaite ce que je réclame ce
qui a existé jusqu'en 1982 c'est quelque
chose qui ne touche pas au salaire
aujourd'hui on est dans l'inverse mais
bon mais donc voilà les échanges avec la
température a été descendue à - 20
degrés quoi bon congélateur mais donc à
la quatrième étage avant cette rencontre
avec tricher on me fait le tour des
locaux et on m'explique comment le plus
trop quoi le mardi à 10 heures du matin
on a appelé d'abord les banques pour
demander
combien de elles veulent de liquidités
et que à ce moment là on décide de leur
donner ce qu'elles veulent plus ou moins
et on met les liquidités sur le marché
et c'est les banques qui prétent les
liquidités et donc se dire que la
monnaie n'est rien d'autre que taper sur
une mettre un chiffre sur un clavier et
taper sur la touche ENTER en disant
maintenant il y a 10 milliards c'est pas
dix milliards c'est plutôt encore plus
que ça toutes les semaines qui sont
envoyées aux banques enfin c'est
délirant se dire que ça n'a pas d'autre
concrétule que ça et donc là ce que je
voyais c'est la nécessité d'un fléchage
de la monnaie c'est à dire que là tu
envoies des liquidités comme dans un
tuyau en espérant que ça arrive dans le
réel c'est à dire les collectivités les
ménages les entreprises sauf que au
passage tu as un tuyau qui est plus que
percé qui est quasiment
augmenter ou tu as l'essentiel qui au
passage va partir dans la spéculation et
donc aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut en
matière de de monnaie c'est évident
qu'il faut une monnaie avec fléchage
faut une monnaie ou tu passes pas par
l'intermédiaire quand pour combattre
l'inflation on fait comment pour
combattre d'abord est-ce que l'inflation
est un combattre
oui non mais attends c'est un espèce de
savate soif tu vois il faut combattre
l'inflation moi j'interroge doit-on
combattre l'inflation
en tout cas ce que j'entends dans la
grande crainte qui nous est offerte
c'est celle de la spirale inflationniste
si jamais on augmente Bernadette et
Géraldine qu'on augmente leur salaire ça
serait là que serait la spirale
inflationniste je réponds il y a une
spirale inflationniste d'abord parce que
il y a des prix type le prix de
l'électricité que vous lier au prix du
gaz sans réalité
et là vous la spirale inflationniste
vous la produisez comme ça et vous
acceptez l'aspect à la place sans
difficulté quand il s'agit des
dividendes ou des salaires des PDG donc
si tu veux et ben ça tu mets un plafond
une limite et que ça soit pas limite
laisse là-dessus et ensuite
l'inflation n'est pas
la peste
tu vois ça dépend à quel niveau elle se
situe mais avoir de l'inflation ça peut
être aussi de l'huile qui est mise dans
les rouages de l'économie donc en soi je
suis pas
pour venir dire qu'il faut à tout prix
avoir une inflation en dessous des deux
pourcents puisque c'est l'obsession de
la Banque centrale européenne
[__] un sujet que tu souhaiterais
aborder avec nous dans toutes tes fiches
les fichiers c'était quoi ces fiches là
j'en compte une deux trois quatre cinq
six sept huit on n'a pas abordé les
retraites mais elles sont tombées
sont pas financés
mais si elles sont financées
tu veux mais tu veux qu'on remette
encore une demi-heure là
il faut que tu reviennes donc un sujet
que tu as envie d'aborder c'est toi
c'est open bar tu choisis le sujet que
tu veux non bah écoute je sais pas
franchement tu m'as déjà fait parler de
plein de trucs tu vois
tu sais pour moi c'est comme un espèce
de filet de sécurité mais que même quand
je vais dans dans les médias je regarde
pas mes trucs mais c'est comme si
j'avais peur de la chute tu vois et de
pas savoir et donc le fait d'avoir ces
trucs là sous mes pieds je me dis au
moins j'ai ça comme une espèce de
sécurité ici les communautés est très
bienveillante quand tu cherches tes mots
tu cherches un raisonnement tu cherches
le nom d'un bouquin il nous le trouve en
une seconde on fait de l'intelligence
collaborative ne soit pas
[Musique]
triste ou ne soit pas ne culpabilise pas
d'avoir des fiches on préfère avoir des
gens comme toi qui est des fiches ou
plutôt qui qui ne passe pas du vent donc
toi tu as des fiches pour pas avoir
c'est du vent et c'est très bien je
bosse ça c'est vrai je bosse tu vois et
j'essaie d'avancer moi ça sent beaucoup
on a préparé cette interview on
t'écoutant te battre
en te battant pour le steak des autres
c'est un peu trivial un résumé
trivialement mais c'est la vérité
tu bosses beaucoup tu vas chercher de
l'info tu hésites pas à mettre en face
de toi les contradictions à nues et
c'est bien trop rare
tu dois te sentir tout seul non non
tu sais ça dépend où d'abord
quand je suis dans mon coin je sais pour
qui je me bagarre tu vois franchement
de visualiser des visages des parcours
des des histoires et de d'être nourris
par ça ça fait que même quand tu arrives
dans l'univers du pouvoir ou de la
représentation du pouvoir
tu es nourri d'une énergie qui fait que
tu voilà tu tu n'abandonnes pas quoi
enfin moi je sais pourquoi je suis là je
sais pourquoi je suis là tu vois puisque
je te parlais des retraites enfin dire
quand tes banquiers d'affaires ou
conseiller chez mckinzee t'as pas de
problème à dire que allez on va
repousser à 65 ans machin bidule truc
moi les gens que j'ai vu dans ma
campagne et qui me parlent de leur
retraite tu donnes des cas tu vois mais
Mauricette son vrai prénom tu vois il y
a des gens qui s'appellent Mauricette
mais agent d'entretien sur une
plateforme logistique on l'appelle
Robocop là-bas pourquoi parce qu'elle a
des bandages au poignet elle tu sais un
truc pour tenir ses hernie autour du dos
les épaules elle se les ai fait opérer
et en fait tu as des tas de gens comme
ça quand ils arrivent à 55 ans 57 ans 58
ans leur corps est marqué par des
opérations successives tu fais raconter
le corps des gens et tu as un récit de
ce que de ce qui est derrière leur
travail mais pas seulement leur travail
a fait endurer donc je veux dire
Mauricette elle a arrêté le boulot il
n'aptitude bon et donc évidemment elle
arrive à 58 ans le temps que ça fasse la
jonction avec l'âge de la retraite
légale pour elle qui sera 62 ans pour
l'instant mais elle a trois quatre ans
dans un tunnel ou elle va se débrouiller
avec des bouts de machin de RSA de trucs
comme ça tu vois et on fait au fond
puisque je t'ai décrit le mouvement qui
a été
celui de la prière peut-être que on
mais le mouvement 2h27 24 secondes le
mouvement qui a été de la prière où on a
on est intéressant on garde on a divisé
par 4
mais va falloir un moment mais euh on a
divisé par 4 le taux de pauvreté des
personnes âgées là en disant parce que
là je la retraite a déjà été repoussée
et tu sais que mécaniquement il est
inscrit déjà dans la loi qui les
repoussé régulièrement et que Macron en
fait il veut accélérer ce report mais
déjà en disant le taux de personnes
senior au RSA donc
grimper de plus
157%. donc il a plus que doublé en
disant ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que les gens comme ils arrivent pas au
boulot à 60 ans il y a plus d'un
Français sur deux qui travaillent plus
bon et donc ça veut dire que comme ils
arrivent pas jusqu'au bout en emploi
soit parce que leur santé ne permet pas
soit parce qu'ils ont été virés du
boulot et qu'ils ont du mal à retrouver
et bien ils ont un espèce de brouillard
de tunnel un truc gazeux entre le moment
ils sont plus en emploi et le moment où
arrive enfin la retraite tu vois et donc
là on rallongeant il est évident que on
va faire simplement du taux de RSA
supplémentaire le retour de la pauvreté
en fait chez les personnes âgées c'est
ça qu'on inscrit te dire que moi le
mouvement que je souhaite c'est non
seulement que ça on le sécurise mais
c'est que au fond ce qu'on a fait dans
la prière pour les personnes âgées il
faut le faire pour la jeunesse
aujourd'hui parce que c'est comme si on
avait inversé un raisonnement de
l'histoire qui était que hier c'était
les personnes âgées dont il était
naturel une fatalité qu'elle
vieillissent au crochet de leurs enfants
tu vois et maintenant c'est comme s'il
était devenu dans l'ordre naturel une
nouvelle fatalité que la jeunesse se
fasse au crochet des parents
tu vois et dans la pauvreté parce que
voilà on a les taux de pauvreté chez les
jeunes et donc et donc en ayant
seulement comme point d'appui la
solidarité familiale
pourquoi la nuque n'a pas voté
l'amendement sur la suppression de la
TVA sur les produits de première
nécessité en tout cas moi j'étais
favorable voilà
j'étais favorable à
je sais pas ce que si j'étais là à ce
moment là mais moi j'étais favorable à
voter pourquoi je voulais dire mais je
veux terminer après sur la jeunesse
pourquoi j'étais favorable à ça parce
que quand je suis passé sur les
ronds-points des gilets jaunes je sais
que j'étais favorable au mouvement des
gilets jaunes avant même le 17 novembre
je m'étais exprimé dessus en disant j'en
serais il y avait une revendication dans
le social c'était la TVA à 0% sur les
produits première nécessité il y avait
une revendication fiscale qui était le
retour de l'impôt sur solidarité sur la
fortune et il y avait une réelle
revendication démocratique qui était
le
Radom d'initiative citoyenne et moi je
fais bien ces trois revendications et
dire que à l'époque tu vois Macron n'a
pas passé de compromis social avec ce
mouvement il a choisi d'y aller par la
matraque par la force d'être dans la
force de coercition donc parler gramshi
tout à l'heure tu vois et que il a cru
par ce biais là et par le blabla du
grand débat que y régler le problème
parce que il redevenait souterrain c'est
à dire qu'en fait un problème qui existe
dans la France depuis 20 30 ans de ce
sentiment d'écrasement des milieux
populaires un écrasement à la fois
matériel mais aussi un accréusement
spirituel de on choisit plus notre
destin et là ça surgit c'est le moment
d'une crise tu vois puisque c'était le
mot crise que tu utilisais au début mais
le crise est aussi un moment qui ouvre
des possibles c'est aussi un moment où
il y a une surgissement d'une vérité et
si à la place de de remettre ça sous le
tapis et on croyant que c'est réglé il
avait passé un compromis social avec ça
je pense que il y aurait pas le même
état d'esprit du pays qui a un état
d'esprit quoi du ressentiment et même
d'un éloignement de la démocratie qui
est évident puisque si la démocratie
c'est ça des Mosses le peuple crate le
pouvoir le pouvoir au peuple ainsi
chaque fois et ben il y a ça se fait
sans les gens contre les gens sans le
peuple contre le peuple à quoi bon la
démocratie mais le même ressentiment le
même sentiment à l'égard de la
démocratie va là encore s'approfondir
sur les retraites de toute façon à la
fin il restera 7 Français sur 10 qui
seront opposés à l'allongement de l'âge
de la retraite et donc Macron voit le
temps dans lequel on se trouve une
usure une fatigue des Français exténués
par deux années de crise covid une
élection qui remporte
sans élan sans enthousiasme
avec presque pas de projet derrière une
majorité radicule à l'Assemblée
nationale mais tu vois dans un coin
comme le mien il arrive même pas les
macronistes arrivent même pas à mettre
un député un candidat sur deux au
deuxième tour je parle même pas d'être
élu dans la Somme ils arrivent pas à
envoyer un candidat sur deux au deuxième
tour et c'est sur cette base sociale
extrêmement fragile avec cette fatigue
avec
la guerre qui produit l'inflation qui
fait et avec les salaires qui suivent
pas avec comment on va payer de factures
pour l'hiver c'est dans ce temps là que
Macron jeudi c'est une folie
c'est une folie je vais même pas sur le
fond de sa réforme sociale mais c'est
une folie pour la démocratie c'est une
folie pour le rapport
ce pouvoir là que de dire que on va
faire ça dans ce moment-là avec cette
Français sur 10 qui sont opposés c'est
évident que peut-être qu'il y arrivera
peut-être qu'il y aura pas des
manifestations monstres j'en serai bien
sûr et peut-être il y aura pas des
manifestations monstres comment tu te
prépares à ça écoute non mais personne
veut le dire mais il y a des manifs
monstrueuses qui sont en train de se
préparer là je l'espère je le souhaite
mais tu sais j'ai pour principe de ne
pas confondre mes prévisions et mes
espérances tu comprends ce que je veux
dire et oui je te dis facture
énergétique t'inquiète pas tu es
prévisions tes anticipations
on verra mais
t'inquiète pas mais on verra on verra tu
sais je sais
moi je vois aussi
à quel la résignation est une force
puissante qui
[Musique]
noient le cœur des gens oublient pas
qu'on est en France ici mais j'espère tu
vois j'espère et je suis un fils de la
Révolution française donc il y a pas de
problème j'en serai et je ferai tout
pour réveiller les gens mais je dis il y
a cette force-là aussi qui existe et on
verra de quel côté ça bascule mais même
s'il y a pas de révolte même si ça se
produit pas ces manifestations monstres
il faut pas croire que dans la durée ça
produit pas des effets
le quand on dit on est contre ça et vous
le faites quand même c'est sous le tapis
c'est sous terrain mais tu sais c'est
presque pire c'est le couvercle qu'on
met sur la marmite et dessous ça pue et
t'as même pas Legé de vapeur tu
comprends ce que tu vois le truc c'est
un peu comme la perruque non comme la
perruque quand ils avaient
donc je disais sur la jeunesse tu vois
le j'essaie de suivre mon film malgré
toi je sais que c'est fait exprès je
sais que c'est comme ça qu'on a j'en
profite c'est comme ça qu'on a les plus
belles interviews quand les gens en fait
se relâchent quand on leur a tellement
le mille mix dans la tête à partir à
gauche à droite c'est là qu'on voit les
vrais gens un peu comme toi non je sais
pas écoute j'essaie de te dire bon fil
quand même mais tu vois si on se repose
que la solidarité familiale elle est
extrêmement injuste aujourd'hui
chez les personnes les plus modestes en
général il donne 13 % de leurs revenus à
leurs enfants chez les personnes les
plus riches il donne 8% seulement de
leurs revenus à leurs enfants mais pour
les uns ça fait 100 euros par mois pour
les autres ça fait 1000 euros par mois
donc pour les uns il y a la possibilité
de s'émanciper de construire son
autonomie de s'inscrire dans la durée
d'aller chercher un logement de tu vois
de tout ça quand chez les autres ça
fonctionne la solidarité familiale
permet de sortir du nid et de d'aller
essayer des choses dans la vie donc
évidemment pour moi ce qu'on a construit
toujours les retraites il faut le
solidifier solidifier la solidarité
après le temps de travail mais il faut
aussi construire une solidarité avant le
travail et pour moi de te dire qu'en
gros ce que je veux faire bien c'est
simplement les Français doivent de leur
travail leur travail présent leur
travail passé quand ils ont travaillé
ils doivent pouvoir vivre dignement de
leur retraite du travail du fruit de
leur travail qu'ils ont effectué mais
aussi les Français doivent pouvoir vivre
du travail à venir quand ils sont jeunes
quand ils sont en formation et que on
doit pas accepter que pendant ce temps
où on grandit et ben ça se fasse dans
dans la pauvreté sous la contrainte
financière question internet bonjour
monsieur Ruffin
quand vous pensez réindustrie
réindustrialisation est-ce que vous
voyez des machines à laver fabriquées à
l'ancienne sans électronique et qui dure
une vie où rapatrier la production
actuelle
c'est une question intéressante en tout
cas peut-être que il y a un certain
nombre de produits où en effet on peut
retrouver le
tu vois le l'usage de mécanique produit
par l'homme je sais pas si en tout cas
sur la machine à laver j'imaginais
plutôt que ça soit une machine à laver
électrique mais peut-être que en effet
c'est pas con
avec le chien qui court
je suis un sport
5 kg par mandat à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est la médecin de l'Assemblée
nationale qui m'avait dit ça ou
peut-être je suis un peu mais quand il
est vague voilà non mais c'est pas
seulement ça c'est un mode de vie assez
sédentaire ou tu es trop voiture tu es
assis tu vois moi j'ai besoin moi de
courir parce que sinon je deviens fou tu
vois et mais tu dis finalement tous les
mecs ils te courent sur les tapis
électriques en face je mets la machine à
laver et tu as de l'énergie qui est
produite de cette manière là
monsieur Ruffin a-t-il l'ambition de
remplacer Jean-Luc Mélenchon
moi mon ambition aujourd'hui c'est de me
demander comment demain
c'est la volonté qui va l'emporter sur
le marché et je sais que ça passe pas
par un individu miraculeux ça passe non
seulement par une équipe entière qui
prend le pouvoir mais c'est pas
seulement ça ça passe par le gars qui
m'a envoyé ce message là c'est à dire
que je crois pas que on
a ouais ça passe pas la transformation
de la société elle passe pas seulement
par les meilleurs tu sais les meilleures
personnes même qui soit sincères qui
soient vraiment dans la volonté de
changer pour la planète et pour les gens
mais si jamais derrière ça pousse pas il
y a rien qui se passera parce que en
face tu as des forces qui sont
extrêmement puissantes et qui vont
demeurer
les institutions d'âge le Medef le Sénat
la Commission européenne la Banque
centrale européenne l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce le FMI tu auras
1000 voix qui est qui viendront répéter
vous ne pouvez pas vous pouvez pas vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez pas vous pouvez
pas et si jamais il n'y a pas une force
populaire puissante qui non seulement
vient dire on peut mais on fait déjà et
ben il y a pas grand chose il se passera
et ça sera pas seulement de la faute
dégâts là-haut et des nanas là-haut
est-ce que tu trouves que il y a un
mouvement civil anti-guerre suffisamment
représentatif ici en France bah là il y
a pas ça n'existe pas aujourd'hui
ce mouvement d'hier qui a pu exister sur
sur l'Irak mais
encore une fois la situation pour moi
est pas la même je mets la situation est
pas la même puisque tu as un pays qui
est clairement envahi et là on est du
côté du pays qui envahit tandis que ce
que dans d'autres situations on s'est
retrouvé comme force d'un gérance et au
fond envahisseur c'est pas la même chose
on n'était pas envahisseur on a porté la
démocratie pour des petites filles c'est
l'une des règles que on peut leçon qu'on
peut peut-être te aussi de la de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est que au fond
ça marche jamais l'ingérence je veux
dire aujourd'hui c'est la Russie qui est
prise dans ce piège mais combien de fois
c'est les États-Unis et leurs alliés qui
en Libye qui en Irak
qui au Sahel
se sont mises dans le même piège où ils
ont cru gagner parce que ils gagnaient
militairement dans des opérations
rapides et à la limite
Poutine était peut-être pas si loin avec
son opération spéciale des premiers
temps d'atteindre Kiev mais de toute
façon dans la durée il peut pas tenir
face à 40 millions du crayon qui ne
veulent pas de lui de la même manière
que les États-Unis et les Alliés ont cru
gagner ailleurs on Afghanistan aussi
mais finalement ce sont des victoires à
la Pyrrhus qui se retournent contre les
forces qui viennent
en ingérence que pense-t-il du revenu de
base je suis pas favorable aux revenus
universel ou revenus de base alors je
suis pas un spécialiste des
différentes modalités mais moi je vais
te dire pourquoi mais je pense qu'il y a
dans la société un certain nombre de
tâches à accomplir est-ce que tu as un
conseil pour les jeunes générations
quelque chose d'intéressable une
bouteille à la mer
il faut qu'il va falloir que tu
reviennes parce qu'il y a des questions
sur le louloute et qui a des questions
sur
BFM
je termine d'ailleurs mais à un moment
il va falloir terminer quand même en
tout cas je fais le mien je fais le mien
cette citation de grammeschi
dont je pense que la jeunesse à travers
les temps difficiles pour le moins qui
va y avoir à traverser il nous faudra
les traverser je fais bien cette phrase
de gramshi qui dit le pessimisme de la
lucidité l'optimisme de la volonté donc
et tu vois dans ta manière de poser des
questions
il y a 1000 raisons d'être pessimistes
il y en a de 1000
il s'agit pas de s'aveugler là-dessus
mais néanmoins même si tu dis bah oui
mais c'est toi le politique
tes citoyens tu es politiques et les
jeunes qui m'écrivent je suis passé des
jeunes mais les gens qui m'écrivent ils
sont citoyens ils sont politiques aussi
tu vois et moi je considère que déjà
avant d'être élu j'étais un intervenant
dans la vie politique et au fond
aujourd'hui tu sais le pouvoir que j'ai
il est rien il est celui de parler et
celui de faire que à travers mon verbe
je je
mets en oeuvre dans le coeur des gens
une force agissante et une force
d'espérance tu vois mais donc notre
devoir et y compris pas seulement pour
les politiques mais c'est quand même
aussi de trouver l'optimisme de la
volonté c'est à dire à travers tous les
obstacles devant nous les montagnes les
méandres de quand même dire voilà il y a
un chemin et à la moi je vois tous les
obstacles je vois tous les bélandes et
en même temps j'ai la conviction que oui
il y a un chemin je veux dire l'humanité
elle a affronter des périls terribles tu
vois quand tu dis Roosevelt
1942 ce qui avait à affronter à l'époque
c'était le mal avec le M majuscule
et il y a eu la force pour vaincre
aujourd'hui je suis je vois très bien
comment il y a des mots
qui existent et je suis convaincu que si
jamais on s'organise si jamais on a la
volonté si jamais l'espérance l'emporte
sur la résignation si jamais les gens se
réveillent tu sais notre mot que j'aime
bien c'est le mot animé animer ça veut
dire réveiller les âmes je me considère
comme étant un animateur démocratique
un lanceur d'alerte député ouais c'est
évident mais aussi j'espère réveiller tu
vois un réveil heure trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté
écoute puisqu'elle vient d'avoir le prix
Nobel physique non Annie Arnaud je pense
que les années est un très beau livre je
sais pas si tu l'as lu c'est une forme
d'autobiographie collective
à suspense donc tu as voilà franchement
c'est
ça raconte 30-45 ans mais découvert à la
fois le lien entre l'intime et
l'universel et c'est toujours beau tu
sais quand à travers une histoire
particulière tu reconnais tu reconnais
dedans et tu vois de l'Université de
l'Intérieur donc les années de Annie
Arnaud ce matin je rencontrais une une
mère isolée et qui me racontait comment
elle a pété un câble un jour parce que à
la fois il fallait qu'elle dépasse ses
enfants à l'école qu'elle avait son
portable qui sonnait avec plus de
logements et Machin et que ça lui est la
température avait chauffé l'on pouvait
plus enfin tu vois un espèce de Burn Out
en direct comme ça d'inflammation je
cherchais je cherchais [__] ça me
rappelle les scènes de livres ça me
rappelle une scène de livre mais
laquelle laquelle Tom Wolf un homme un
vrai t'as pas lu ça regarde bon voilà
c'est donc ça je te donne deux romans
c'est
un pavé de 900 pages qui s'avalent comme
et alors bon la fin je pense qu'on peut
se priver de 200 300 dernières pages
quoi mais sinon et puis d'ailleurs
puisqu'on en parler de la difficulté à
être chez les riches tu vois je te
disais le Monaco il yacho et tout ça et
autant l'univers des pauvres je n'ai pas
vu quand ils sont vraiment pauvres ils
sont dans la rue donc pour les observer
c'est facile pour les interroger c'est
facile l'univers des riches il faut
avoir des codes et parfois des codes de
sens propre puisqu'il faut taper des
codes sur des portes pour rentrer chez
eux alors que les pauvres t'as pas tapé
de code pour rentrer chez eux bon et
donc et là Tom volts c'est la force de
la littérature aussi c'est qui t'ouvre
les portes tu vois il y a des scènes de
chez des dirigeants d'entreprises dans
le monde des requins de la finance qui
sont stupéfiantes dans un homme un vrai
après puisque je t'ai parlé mais ça va
être là beaucoup plus un classique pour
toi et pour
tes spectateurs je pense c'est aux
internautes tes internautes c'est la
société arrive gouvernable de Chamayou
qui est qui raconte ce que je te raconte
t'es avec Huntington et crises ici tu
vois et qui vient
montrer comment la société qui n'était
pas gouvernable qui ou les dirigeants
avaient du mal à diriger dans les années
70 parce que le peuple était à l'époque
réveillé animé tu vois et donc comment
il y a une reprise en main qui s'est
effectuée par quelqu'un
Friedman mais aussi par des théories de
management tout ça et je pense que voilà
il offre une lecture de ce qui nous
arrive aujourd'hui parce que je te
parlais de j'ose pas et de d'ouvrir la
parenthèse libérale l'enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est de fermer la parenthèse libérale
tu vois de
au fond même toute façon elle est déjà
en partie fermée mais aujourd'hui tu es
plus sur du libéral libéral Macron qui
se présentait comme un libéral libéral
libéral sur le plan économique mais
aussi libéral sur le plan sociétal il se
montre en vérité libéral autoritaire
tu vois tu as un autre livre à nous
conseiller
qu'est-ce que le colonel Chabert si tu
veux faire du classique tu vois parce
que moi j'aime beaucoup la littérature
ah bah tiens un livre qui a compté pour
toi plus tôt mais franchement alors
là je suis cité des livres qui ont
compté pour moi mais
dans ma formation
quand je suis tombé sur question de
sociologie de Pierre Bourdieu on peut
dire que ça transformait mon existence
voilà j'ai eu une épiphanie le dernier
chapitre de question sociologique qui
s'appelle le racisme de l'intelligence
je peux dire vraiment que c'est une
forme de crise mystique je veux dire que
le temps s'est arrêté
spatio-temporel
et j'ai tous ces troublés en moi
et je sais pas si à ce moment là ça a
duré une minute 10 minutes ou une heure
tu gardes ce moment là parce que quand
tu vas revenir pour la prochaine
interview on va repartir à partir de
maintenant d'accord sur l'épiphanie
François Ruffin merci merci à toi
[Musique]